[Laughter]
hey everybody it's friday evening yep
what's everybody doing out there
we're just trying to um
get a little bit of drink off
we're not going anywhere tonight but
we're just gonna um you know we're going
out on sunday night actually going to
momentum mario on sunday night but we're
not going out too late yeah there's dave
he's going to be going to mannequins
later on yeah uh yeah he said [ __ ]
that's how i start my night at
mannequins get me a 30 ounce bottle what
coal 45 yeah well we haven't uh that's
the thing and i think did we start
talking about it on the on the wednesday
show right i kind of feel like we were
talking about it
or or
what talking about colt 45 and all the
cheap yeah i don't remember if it was
the wednesday show if it was one of the
movie reviews yeah yeah i don't remember
either i don't remember either but it
was something in the last week yeah i
think it might have been on wednesday
and uh i think we mentioned it a couple
times i think and we uh decided so tom
when he was out at the store a couple
days ago he picked up a couple of uh
yeah
i couldn't find couldn't find kane cobra
and i couldn't find [ __ ] schlitz malt
liquor bowl did they not make it anymore
maybe they make it anymore they make it
it's just they don't sell it around here
but i got colt 45 i got two i got two
different kinds
i got the [ __ ] standard colt 45 and i
got the [ __ ] colt 45 high gravity
the black one
high gravity
i have no idea is it going to make you
like float up to the ceiling like
charlie bucket and his grandfather
will he walk no it's high gravity it
makes you heavier
you put it on you get you get [ __ ] we
gain some more weight
yeah i don't need that maybe that's why
they're calling it that it's like
so like the low-key thing
it gets you the more of it you drink it
gets you closer and closer
floor which actually if that's what they
are closer to the
were thinking that's actually pretty
brilliant i don't know somebody can look
it up
i'm sure it means something
maybe it's uh the heavier stuff that
falls down to the bottom of the [ __ ]
fat the sediment to sediment
[Laughter]
the high the higher gravity [ __ ]
sediment that's probably thicker
we'll see we'll see
but um
i'll uh i'll fire up the [ __ ] cult 45
when uh when the time is right i'm not
going to [ __ ] start to show off with
that we'll put we'll we'll yeah you
don't want to blow the load like that
early on in the show
we're in for the long haul we're in this
[ __ ] for the long haul when we're
probably like so drunk that we're not
even going to know what it tastes like
it's up to you yeah well well the thing
about it is that i don't recall
ever having
drank cold 45 min i very well may have
like sometime in my 20s or something and
i just don't remember
but uh so you will probably be a better
judge than me because you know i i don't
have any uh baseline comparison i've had
it like well that's what i'm saying but
like i don't know if i've ever had it if
i did it was so long ago that i don't
remember i haven't had it in recent
years you know last time i had it i was
a kid i was in the army and it was just
floating around in the barracks you
drank what people bought
yeah you know well yeah that's i've
already told you what you do i'll tell
you what you do already stories later
but you know it's just
you know [ __ ]
colt 45 was something that the brothers
would buy you know what i mean you just
drink up all your beer they started
offering you that and [ __ ] you're
drinking that and you [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] up i remember liking it but then
uh you're [ __ ] you [ __ ] white yo
you're you're you're white squad amazing
no no no they trying to take it from you
no no no they're trying to revoke your
white card and [ __ ] that's [ __ ] funny
you know and then they're all laughing
about it oh no no we're darkening them
up some you know kind of just they're
just it's it's imagine like
an infantry barracks is kind of like a
cross between a frat house and a [ __ ]
maximum security prison it's like that
sounds super fun
but uh yeah well actually i was telling
tom i was like before we started the
show
i was like maybe because this is such a
fun little thing and we never thought of
it before and i don't know why we didn't
think of it before i said maybe
every week like when we're buying
the regular booze for the show we
actually have rum today rather than
vodka i got like rum and orange juice
and pineapple juice and it's delicious
but i said maybe when we go to the
liquor store every week maybe we should
look for either canned cocktails or just
like a little what like maybe one of the
little bottles of something that seems
like a really weird flavor that maybe
would be fun
to taste test on the show to see what is
i was like maybe maybe we should make
that a thing
well you see when i went down there i
had i went to like four different places
to go to i was looking for king cobra
so i go uh
to the um
to the look to the little [ __ ]
redneck the junky [ __ ] redneck
[ __ ]
country
[ __ ] the farm uh uh liquor store they
they had a lot of stuff in there all
right and the woman working in there
she's just kind of a large marge type
you know and that's did her face go
yeah
and i'm like look i got i got this
youtube show and i gotta get oh you told
her the whole story yeah yeah i figured
you probably yeah because he was gone
for a while and he came back and he's
like yeah i had to go like a whole bunch
of different places
and it says i i found now it says i
gotta i i'm gonna [ __ ]
i gotta get [ __ ] cold 45 kid cobra
and [ __ ] slit small liquor balls he
goes uh-huh and i said i got the cult 45
i can't find i can't find the king cobra
and and and uh
the [ __ ] schlitz malt liquor bowl and
she goes so you trying to do a taste
test on all the [ __ ]
you're like yeah essentially i was like
yeah and she
and she goes well let's see if we can
find it you know and she's looking
around in there and she's like
nope
we don't have king cobra we don't have
this malt liquor bull yeah we've got
colt 45
and you know high gravity and i already
i already had the regular one i got the
regular one [ __ ] circle k the white
one so i bought the black one the high
gravity this is okay yeah let me get one
of those because you want some hurricane
it's a hurricane
and i said i don't think i want to try
it you know this is i'm just trying to
look for stuff that's famous and she
goes oh hurricane's famous
i said it is
famous in sanford
there you go
it's famous in sanford
and uh i said no i'll save that until
later and she goes all right you know
she's like that you know she was
laughing because you'd be drinking some
[ __ ] there that's some shitty [ __ ] right
there that's some shitty [ __ ] yeah
zach even says oof hurricane
i've never heard of him i've heard of it
but like a long time ago i got hurricane
but i said maybe it's like i said that
might be a fun thing to do it doesn't
always have to be like cheap shitty [ __ ]
it maybe it could be that sometimes but
i kind of feel like maybe if we go to
the liquor store especially around here
i'm sure there's like some really like
scary like rednecky uh liquor stores so
maybe we could go there and like find
either really cheap shitty [ __ ] or
something that's like weird like you're
like that is gonna be disgusting let's
try that out well there was a lot of
stuff like that in there that's what i'm
saying
so that might be like it doesn't have to
be the whole show or nothing like that
but it's like that might be like a fun
thing to start doing since we're already
drinking anyway you get that [ __ ] down
and probably obt
maybe yeah some of those things down on
obt [ __ ] some of those liquor stores
down dave says you gotta go to pine
hills for all them favorites
yeah yeah you got to go where the
projects are and have all that that's
what i mean so then you could get some
kind of stuff but like i said it doesn't
necessarily have to be just that kind of
stuff it could be other kind of stuff
just like weird-ass flavors not
i mean i don't want to like spend a [ __ ]
ton of money on it obviously because i
don't have a lot of money but you could
maybe get like i said if they had like
those weird little airplane
uh sample size bottles of like some
[ __ ] weird-ass flavor or something
like that they had all kinds of stuff in
there
what i'm saying
i don't want to buy like a whole big
thing of some [ __ ] i'm not going to
drink that's the redneck store yeah yeah
the cracker store everything around the
cracker package store
they had all kinds of crackage stores
crackers
yeah in other words that's what i'm
going to start a large marge working
[Laughter]
when she's not driving she's not driving
the big rig she was like four foot eight
so she wasn't that large no she'd pick
around she was oh okay big around yeah
she was funny she was semi-large marge
yeah she was young though
she's about 30. you know
oh you get oh you're drinking the [ __ ]
you're trying to you're gonna turn it
you're like yeah you're reviewing the
[ __ ]
yeah that's some real [ __ ] there that's
terrible
but you see this is the thing that's
what this is this is part of this
[ __ ] taste test all right
i remember it being better than
budweiser
that's not really that high of a bar to
clear uh gonna say
white dudes are defending budweiser and
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] [ __ ] you know like
it's really the hill they want to die
they were going no no no no don't drink
that the brothers are like no man drink
malt liquor it's better than that [ __ ]
right there you know and i'd be tasting
them both and i was going like yeah that
malt liquor is better just yeah i told
you i mean i will agree that it's more
smooth
it's more smooth
generally better than like yeah that's
more spot
yeah that's just like that piss water
there man of course i haven't had
budweiser in a very long time right
um so maybe they've improved it
but
i doubt it i kind of i doubt why why
mess with the winner because people
still [ __ ] buy the [ __ ] right
for their super bowl parties or whatever
i don't know back in there what 1990
1992 tonight late 1994 era
for the money i remember
in in the [ __ ] in a military type
situation malt liquor was more bang for
the buck
yeah you know what i mean it tasted
better it was smoother
you got drunker off of it per dollar
and i remember liking it better
what was that [ __ ] that used to be i
don't know if they still sell it anymore
i don't remember what it's called but
what was that [ __ ] that um
that came in like the the
bottle that was kind of like it kind of
was like flask
shaped i want to say mad dog was it mad
dog yeah and it kind of tasted and
looked like jolly rancher flavors like
it was black dog 20 20. that's right
yeah i've had that a few times too and
i'm like you know this isn't bad yeah no
it's not good and that'll [ __ ] you up
too it tastes good
i think that's another one that's just a
malt liquor yeah it's like a malt drink
it's not that strong but it's it was
cheap right and
wine
um
you could definitely tell it's like
super super fruity flavored it's like
yeah it was like a jolly rancher like a
jolly rancher but boozy yeah
yeah but we used to drink it i'm telling
you man yeah i tried it too it's all
right yeah there's nothing wrong with it
it was uh it we had i'll taste test that
[ __ ] if it shows there's another show
yeah if it showed up
if it showed up in the barracks we
[ __ ] drank it when you see um
what what was happening is that a payday
would all happen for everybody at once
okay so guys would run down to our
[ __ ] local
[ __ ] liquor stores
and uh
buy some [ __ ] for yourself and say [ __ ]
it i'm gonna buy some [ __ ] for everybody
else too
you know what i mean sure
because
it didn't cost much not back in those
days it was right outside [ __ ] fort
gates fort campbell
so you could go like yeah give me like
uh 20 bottles of [ __ ] mad dog
didn't cost you that much right yeah i
mean i think they're like three dollars
a bottle
at that time maybe 250 something didn't
cost most of 30 bucks you could hook it
hook everybody up you know and you'd
have a [ __ ] party and other guys are
bringing like
stakes and [ __ ] we'd put the grill
out and [ __ ] start grilling and stuff
you had like [ __ ] seven competing
[ __ ] jam boxes
everybody brought their [ __ ] music
like seven of them all competing for
airspace out there but
it was
[ __ ] you know what i'm talking
about right yeah yeah
[ __ ]
yeah you couldn't hear either they're
singing
boom boxes yeah boom boxes like five of
them you know and they're all [ __ ]
trying to outdo each other you can't
hear a second one of them
and um
you know it's just
[ __ ] funny but i remember that [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
we just [ __ ] got
the cheapest [ __ ] possible so you could
get more of it
but we had we got mad dog another one
that we get was [ __ ] thunderbird
another one that showed was [ __ ] wild
irish rose
oh yeah i remember that and then there
was some other one white something or
other white rock no white what was that
[ __ ]
yeah what was it white lightning no
there was all kinds of [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] that we were buying
jj said back in high school here in
canada we would shoulder tap for colt 45
old english and crest old english have
you guys tried crest do we even have
that here crest is toothpaste i'm sure
you probably have that in canada too but
i have never heard of any yeah mango
remembers thunderbird camp guy brings up
boone's farm strawberry wine yeah i
remember that being all right that's
wine no that was different than mad dog
mad dog wasn't really wine
it
i think it might have been a little bit
stronger than wine i think it was a was
what you would call a malt beverage
and it was [ __ ] came in like a glass
flask
and it was
real strong in flavor then it was like
like super punch flavor super
green apple and
they were like kids flavors
yeah i remember they're good yeah i
remember those they were good they
tasted like
remember those [ __ ] ice icicle pops
that you put in your refrigerator like
otter pops otter pops like yeah they
tasted like melted otter pops i call
pookie i don't sit there and drink them
because they're little tail sticks up
like the end of it outer pop yeah
and then uh
i remember old english old english was
another malt liquor that was a good one
i don't think i ever drank it but i
remember seeing it in the store
like i said english i didn't really
start e at the end of it i think well
yeah because then it's it's fancy
because it's fancy it added that added
five cents to the [ __ ] box
that extra e yeah mango said it is a
diamond white diamond white maybe yeah
it's been a long time there was weird
ones man like [ __ ] tomahawk and [ __ ]
like that it showed dude
by the tomahawk and it came in a bigger
bottle from what i remember
yeah but that's his thing it's like we
go in liquor stores all the time but
usually we're pretty laser focused i'm
like yeah i gotta go get my sky or
whatever yeah and then i don't really
like look around at any of the other
stuff
so i don't really know what's available
or what they still make or anything like
that well the [ __ ] that i'm talking
about that we were drinking into army
man
that was
in the barracks okay in a barracks party
situation
that was [ __ ] rock bottom ghetto
ghetto ghetto drinking you know we it
was the
the cheaper the better the the fruitier
well it was like it was like something
you give to a kid because like we were
kids we just didn't realize it you know
we [ __ ]
give the alcohol to the kids it's like a
kid friendly alcohol
even the cigarettes get them started
even well they knew how to attract they
knew how to attract people in their 20s
to buy something
real bright colors and everything you
know [ __ ] real strong flavors and
fruity flavors not gonna lie that would
still work on me nowadays even the
cigarettes that we were buying you know
i mean if they had a really cool pack
we'd buy it and we uh well yeah looking
back on us like man that pack isn't real
cool looking but we thought it was cool
like one of the ones that we were buying
just for the pack was called magna
cigarettes called magna they were a red
pack and it had kind of like a a round
disc it looked like chrome and it said
magnus it looked like a [ __ ] ornament
like the magna carta yeah like the
magikarp
that's some important [ __ ] they were
good cigarettes though it's just that
you know you could definitely it looked
like a damn album cover yeah you know
what i mean packaging is very important
hey i'm a graphic designer man i've been
doing that [ __ ] since like the mid 90s
yeah so i know how
how packaging is like really does like
affect people's you know that's just the
way people are
uh mastit mastittle says isn't strong
white cider a thing in the u.s it's the
go-to for kids drinking in parks and
alcoholics over here in the uk
strong white cider never heard of it not
really that's not a thing
over here they'd probably call that mad
dog 2020. probably yeah which is like i
kind of feel like i don't really know
what the kids today are doing because
i'm thunderbird because i'm almost 50
but um
i don't know i kind of feel like when we
were kids
everybody was just well you didn't have
a lot of money so you just drank
whatever was cheap and that was usually
like malt liquor and that would like
[ __ ] you up you hired a bum to go get
your booze for you well yeah because you
couldn't buy it right so you had to like
so yeah you had to give a bomb you find
a bomb and you say hey man we need
something oh you want some drink okay
i'll get you what do you want okay give
me the money he'd go over there he'd get
what he wanted and go in there and he'd
buy a bunch of [ __ ]
and [ __ ] he go you come back any time
you know he you try to cut him he
[Laughter]
never got ripped off by a bomb either
but what they but what they would do is
they wouldn't give it to you they would
set it down and take what they wanted
and walk away
because they didn't want to get filmed
giving it to a kid well yeah pretend
like they've they lost them forgot it
yeah
and um [ __ ] we had a regular we had a
regular wino
[ __ ] they would hang out out in south
gate [ __ ] did he ever recognize
anything to you guys like he's like hey
try some of this too no no we were
getting we were getting southern comfort
because southern comfort had a lot of
bang for the buck and you could drink it
straight
i mean you know what i don't mind
southern comfort oh and i'm not you know
and i'm not proud like a few times when
i was uh single and this is when i was
in my 30s and i was like live in an
apartment here in orlando every now and
then i'd have a bottle of southern
comfort around thing i'm like you know
what i'm putting i'm pouring this [ __ ]
in my coffee in the morning it's going
to be one of those kind of days
yeah you know what i mean bernie people
don't have a southern comforter
it comes in a whiskey bottle
it's kind of like a
kind of like a liqueur to whiskey kind
of like drambuie but [ __ ] real cheap
well not real cheap just cheap
um
nowadays it would probably be something
like fireball or um
i don't know what would be equivalent to
that
fireball is a lot hotter more cinnamon
flavor this was kind of swedish they're
sweet
that's kind of sweet kind of a honey
whiskey flavor
kind of like a cheap cheaper version of
drambuie but not as thick as drambuie
nowhere near as expensive kind of like
um
kind of like that jack daniels apple
or jack okay i like honey i like that
daniel's honey it's probably about
would be closer to it
you could probably get that a lot easier
i liked that jack daniels honey somebody
gave me a bottle of it a few years ago
for christmas
and
uh yeah i thought that was pretty good
the apple's good too
honestly other day a couple weeks back
when we were at uh ibarr well slash
barbarella a friend of ours had because
you can you can only buy like the
cocktails and stuff because they don't
have their liquor license [ __ ] yet so a
lot of people bring
hard liquor and you know you can just go
out in the parking lot and kind of have
a little tailgate
so a friend of ours had some of the
apple whiskey i don't think it was jack
daniels it was uh
something else but it was yeah it was
the apple stuff and uh so we all went
out there and had shots of that but man
he was [ __ ] up at the end of the night
he was just like i mean not not in a bad
way he was just he was really john smith
saying the first time i got seriously
drunk was on southern comfort it still
haunts him yeah
southern comfort and oracle says
southern comfort always makes me think
of blanche from streetcar named desire
oh yeah there you go um always dependent
on the kindness what's funny is that the
first thing i got just [ __ ] blasted
on was in in brazil i think i was must
have been about 16
and
it was on um
chivas regal
chivas regal scotch whiskey
and i for to this day i cannot drink
chivas regal i kind of feel like that
happens to a lot of people like with if
they have like a really bad drama their
first time which most people do yeah i
can't i can't drink it um
i can drink any other kind of scotch but
just not shivers regal because it'll
instantly well because they all have a
very distinct yeah i was like oh man i
can't drink it i nearly almost start
throwing up soon as i smell it yeah i i
threw up for [ __ ] like a day
i i had to have had alcohol poisoning
i mean that's right yeah probably
[ __ ] yeah i felt like i probably
almost died because i remember slamming
it getting so drunk i just [ __ ] slam
a glass of it and then after a while
you're drunk and you're not really
paying attention anymore so you're just
like whatever i'm having more and then
yeah passed out and woke up it was like
the next day and my [ __ ] head was
just boom boom boom
yeah which reminds me i meant to go to
dollar general and get some more aspirin
today because all my aspirin is gone i
didn't realize i only had one left in
the bottle and it's gone now but um i
didn't john smith said in glasgow we
have buckfast which is a sickly wine
mixed with an energy drink which has a
devastating effect hence its nickname
wreck the house juice
[Laughter]
camp guy also says i knew a dude in high
school totally normal he skipped school
one day and went out drinking with
another friend ended up running from the
cops and wrecking his car in downtown
atlanta ran up a guy wire and also puked
in the cop car yeah that was quite a day
yeah that was like some ferris bueller's
day off [ __ ] except like probably not as
fun ending up with people getting
arrested i never had anything i i never
did anything that bad
i've never been arrested actually no
that i'm thinking about it
i don't even think i've become clue all
the [ __ ] i did i got away with yeah
that's right but um yeah so uh zach is
asking you for some advice hey tom yeah
i think i pulled a muscle in both arms
while lifting the other day i thought
you would be with like one muscle in
both arms or both muscles and one i
thought he's going to be beating off
yeah well maybe it will i don't we don't
know we're just going by what
historically you want what do you want
uh it feels like bad tennis elbow on
both arms and has for a few days what do
i do keep lifting it happen because
you're weak
is that it's just that simple
just to heal up continue to lift
when you're when you're weak
and you first start lifting you hurt
yourself all right reduce some of the
weight a little bit
um but your tendons will get [ __ ]
better at your joints and everything i
know you're still pretty young so you
don't have to worry about things like
hormonal balancing or anything yet you
should still be hormonally in pretty
good shape
um
i remember when i started picking up
lifting
once i really started getting into it
and started to [ __ ] increase weight
i'd [ __ ] be doing things like curls
and i could feel my forearms creaking
from the bones not being quite
strong enough to support that amount of
weight like i could feel that they were
kind of slightly flexing
and all that goes away in time you know
what i mean when you're
working bones they'll [ __ ] harden up
and
tendons that can get better
um
your joints can build a little bit more
fluid in them but a lot of that has to
do
well you have to be young
being young helps being on hrt and other
things helps also to keep your joints
everything heals up so much faster
and your system is running so much
better
you know you're
you're adding the right kind of fuel to
the fire to keep all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
healed up
um so no just if you're gonna have these
little aches and pains you can pull
muscles and just work through it just
keep going
you'll you'll break in you know it's
like breaking in a set of shoes you know
you'll just they'll you know it'll work
out work itself out your body has a real
good
if everything's normal your body has a
real amazing
ability to heal up and to strengthen and
to change things
you know just you got some people are
just when you have people sometimes
they're like oh i can't i'll just hurt
myself i'm like this and oh no i can't
work out my back and
it's all [ __ ] okay the uh the
problem with them is mental
they're mentally weak they don't like
they see it as pain
so they quit
it's not pain though like i
once you get to a certain amount or
strength it only takes a couple months
really
it starts to feel good you start feeling
like endorphins and it doesn't you
doesn't feel like you're working that
hard
you know
i like i said man i can't believe i got
done with that session i feel like i
didn't really work that hard and then i
[ __ ] had that was well i did eight
sets eight sets of [ __ ] start at 15
and then worked out of ten
that's a lot you know but you know you
don't feel it after a while
just feels normal
and you're not even sore afterwards
it's like you didn't do anything but
you're getting bigger
mango says uh the apple jack daniels
really surprised me how good it was it
is very good it's like way better than
it has any right to be i mean i'm not
i'll defend jack daniels i like regular
jack daniels i like a good jack and coke
uh every now and again but yeah that
apple one i bought it like just not too
long after it first came out and i was
like oh that sounds kind of good um but
yeah it was like way better than i
expected the honey one is actually
really good too didn't we actually buy
some of that peanut whiskey
did we ever buy that yeah i remember
that being pretty good yeah it was
pretty good
i can't remember what brand it was
because i was like ooh it's like that
sound it was just kind of gross but also
delicious at the same time because
peanuts i love peanuts yeah and i love
whiskey it was peanut butter how can
that go wrong it was peanut butter yeah
i think that was uh
that was the company you used to work
for no no no that um
it was a it was a completely different
one okay yeah yeah what i was doing with
that is i was because that was vodka and
it was pb and j vodka okay
and some of that stuff of a salt in the
rim of the glass and then put yeah that
was the um that was van gogh that's
where i used to work for i don't even
know if they make that anymore yeah but
when i was working there back in
i think it was 2013.
van gogh vodka
used to make uh their big flavor when i
first started working there that they
were launching was pb and j
because this was right when a bunch of
vodkas were you know obviously like
flavored vodkas were like really really
big in the market then
so
i think another brand i can't remember
what it was uh maybe it was stolen i
don't remember what it was but they had
done like a peanut butter flavor and it
was really successful so they're like oh
let's do pb and j like a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich now the thing about
their
van gogh i will say their [ __ ] was a
little bit expensive but they used all
real flavors they didn't use like
artificial flavors so they actually
tended to taste a lot better they didn't
have that like weird i don't mind um
pinnacle or anything like that because
it's cheap uh depends on what flavor it
is though some of them are kind of like
weird chemically fake tasting but van
gogh their stuff always tasted like
really good and really robust but like i
said they cost about twice as much as uh
pinnacle does maybe more
but they did a pb and j one
and the thing about it that was that to
me that vodka i didn't taste any jelly
in there at all and to do their
signature cocktail which we actually
tried out because they had a bar in the
office because it was a liquor company
and you would come in like on friday
afternoons and they're like here's our
new signature cocktail with this new
flavor that we're doing so we want
everybody to try it to like get
everybody's opinion
and when they did their uh signature
cocktail
it was the peanut butter and jelly vodka
but then you had to put a little bit of
raspberry vodka in it too
like to pump up the jelly flavor because
i feel like the pb and j vodka despite
the j
didn't really have
that much jelly flavor it was mostly
just peanut it was good but it mostly
just tasted like peanut but what we got
at the store that time if we ever got it
i remember thinking about getting it
that was whiskey that wasn't vodka it
was peanut whiskey
and i remember thinking that that
sounded like really good because i know
it might sound gross to some people but
i don't think we got that maybe we
didn't maybe we just thought about it
and then we just never got around to it
because i think it was kind of expensive
so i was like well i don't know if i'm
going to like it so i don't want to pay
all that money
you know what i mean i should have maybe
bought a little one
when it came to the flavored whiskies
the best ones i've had so far were that
was that i think it was jack daniels i
think the jack that was j i think it was
jack daniels
apple and the jack daniels honey those
two right there yeah they had another
one i think it was cinnamon
one of the cinnamon one it was kind of
it was kind of kind of like maybe it was
kind of like uh
i had it at the biker bar
oh well i wasn't there so what do you no
somebody bought me a shot of it it's
kind of like fireball
see i can't drink i you know i love
cinnamon in other contexts i think i've
said this before like i really like i
love cinnamon toast and cinnamon toast
and i like cinnamon in my coffee and
[ __ ] like that but fireball like
anything that's like super cinnamon like
fireball or red hots or anything like
that i can't do it it gives me like
instant heartburn i like it instant
heartburn yeah i likes i like fireball
i know you do yeah david june said i
wanted to be a show-off at 16 and i
chugged almost an entire fifth of soco
at a party woke up outside with puke in
my boots
with soco
never heard of that
zach says when i broke up with my long
time girlfriend years ago my diet for
about two weeks consisted of nothing but
ever clear maybe a cheese doodle here
and there
man i remember one time oh my god i
remember one time up in mississippi we
were having a [ __ ] party
um this was uh right before i joined in
the army all right so it must have been
uh 1990.
we were over
my cousin david key's house i call him a
cousin we're not really related that's a
weird thing about in mississippi is
you're gonna be there's all these
cousins that you have that you're
actually not related to
but if your family and his family and
their family has been around they've
known each other for generations their
cousins
like if your dads are friends or your
moms were friends and
it's just just i guess just a different
culture
so um but you treat each other as
cousins
we made a punch bowl all these girls
were coming over
everybody had graduated from high school
and some of them were going off to
college and stuff
and we made a punch bowl and we were
[ __ ] bought a thing ever clear and we
were admit we were making the punch okay
and had a big old punch bowl
and the ever clear that we had came in a
can
a giant can like
remember how the old uh hawaiian punch
used to come in a can and you took a
[ __ ] oh yeah remember those things
remember the hawaiian punch cans yeah
this is [ __ ] mississippi [ __ ] ever
clear you want a goddamn can
what was that
what happened i don't know
oh i guess it was pokey yeah she was
down there farting around
so
took the damn can opener and put the two
holes in it poured the whole [ __ ] can
into that [ __ ] patch ball that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] deadly
and uh there was a little bit of um
everclear [ __ ] caught on a rim and
[ __ ] joey rooter was [ __ ] standing
next to his name was reuter
joey ruder was standing next to me
and i said i bet and i had a cigarette
burn in my mouth i said i bet you
that'll touch fire and he's like yeah it
would and the [ __ ] hit it like
and it [ __ ] the whole can expanded
and it became a rocket engine
whoops because of all the fumes inside
the [ __ ] cat yeah that one those two
[ __ ] jets [ __ ] shot out like that
and that thing got hot as [ __ ] and it
got it blew out a bit it almost got
basketball shaped
like that whoa
it only went for about three seconds and
it was and i had to drop it it was
[ __ ] smoking hot
and then [ __ ] joey laughed his ass
off and he goes that became a goddamn
bottle rocket you know i thought yeah
[ __ ] it surprised me
how did most dudes make it to adult age
i don't know
i don't know
do it don't do it
that's what i'm just saying i thought it
[ __ ] flex i was gonna say you might
have looked like [ __ ] fake by the
opera things got a little bit different
yeah
we were [ __ ] nuts a couple couple day
a couple years before that
behind that same house we had some woods
out there
and a tree with a rope that hang out
that hung out
hanging off a tree and a little [ __ ]
hill there and we would [ __ ] jump off
that hill and grab that rope and swing
we stole some gasoline
from the lawn mower
you know because you know and we poured
the gasoline on the [ __ ] ground and
set it on fire we were swinging through
the gasoline
and we were drunk of course of course
and we were drunk yeah so you were extra
flammable yeah
getting getting drunk out there
listening to the twisted sister
looking right yeah
[Laughter]
twisted sister i'm just gonna say i'm
just gonna say two words natural
selection naturals twisted sister and
[ __ ] twisted sister and [ __ ] uh uh
what was the other one that we were
really quiet right so you're not gonna
take it yeah yeah and then anyway right
and [ __ ] uh we were listening what
was that quiet riot song that was all
the rage my mama's is all dancing now i
don't remember i don't remember the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] was the name of
that thing
come on come on field annoying come on
if you don't know us yeah we played that
[ __ ] over and over again play that into
the ground just that one album and then
we were playing [ __ ] def leopard and
iron maiden
and and uh british steel and [ __ ]
screaming for vengeance and we played
that [ __ ]
and um
so
we had the wall of fire going and we
were swinging through
it drinking [ __ ] like mad dog and
[ __ ] crap like that
and
the [ __ ] fire
we did that a couple times the fire
would burn and it would go out
it was like some dude like joey or
[ __ ] david he'd go out there and he'd
[ __ ] make the wall of fire again and
he would touch fire to it
well
we were swinging through it we noticed
that
the wall of fire went all the way to
where the gas can was
and then a gas can caught on fire uh-oh
it was one of those plastic gas cans
yeah yeah
[ __ ]
it [ __ ] jumped up and went in a
little spigot yeah called a donkey dick
all right it's a plastic donkey dick
coming off the top of that [ __ ] gas
cat and it was five gallons of [ __ ]
gasoline
and it went up and it caught the tip of
that [ __ ]
donkey dick
on fire and it started to burn and it
started to burn like a [ __ ] like a
candle or you know what i mean because
the fumes were coming out
and it was just one
like that and you could see that
and me and joey and somebody else think
it was paul moss run up to it and we're
throwing dirt on it trying to get it to
go out
and [ __ ] it's going smaller getting
shorter and shorter and shorter you know
the the [ __ ] donkey dick is it's
melting as it's going like a fuse and
when it gets down like that it gets to
be about three inches long we go get
that guy we just scream and i'll run
from that thing and that thing [ __ ]
went up boom
you can feel the [ __ ] shock wave
come from it yeah [ __ ] crazy and then
burning gasoline went down the hill
and it just caught part of the woods on
fire all right but luckily luckily it
was too wet for it to go very far
we were worried
because
it wouldn't burn down
wouldn't burn down david's house
but there was another house on the other
side of the [ __ ] woods
you know i mean a
couple hundred yards that that house
would have burned up
yeah that's how [ __ ] crazy we were
i forgot the shotgun too because we were
out there with a [ __ ] semi-auto
12-gauge shotgun
yeah for sure yeah
we [ __ ] get
the the
i'm embarrassed about this [ __ ]
are you ready oh this is getting yeah
yeah yeah
let's hear some more embarrassing
stories indiana jones stuff the [ __ ]
the the rope
we had the end of the rope tied
in a [ __ ] little loop so you could
jump up on it and you could grab it and
put your foot in it and start swinging
all right and you throw somebody the
shotgun
and it was a it was like somebody's it
was david's dad's [ __ ]
uh
[ __ ] duck gun you know for hunting
ducks so it had like a 26 inch [ __ ]
[ __ ] full choke [ __ ] barrel on it
you know it was a [ __ ] big old long
semi-auto shotgun
probably had about five rounds in it
four or five rounds
in the in the tubular magazine another
one the chamber we'd load that [ __ ] all
up and we'd start you start swinging on
it and somebody throw you the shotgun
and as you're swinging you're trying to
shoot at targets we'd have targets out
there just throw a can out there you're
swinging and trying to shoot it at the
same time while you drop through the
wall of fire
it's evil knievel [ __ ]
yeah i forgot all about that crap
ultimately you know like thank you i
don't know how we live thank god for the
internet because it is mississippi man
at least now people are just mostly
getting drunk in their own houses and
just like playing video games and stuff
so they're not like out like causing
massive destruction or killing
yeah it wasn't it wasn't burning down
entire like rainforests yeah
it wasn't it wasn't buckshot it was it
was birdshot you know so
we grew up around it we knew what we
were doing that's why we were you know
we were good with guns but it was just
bird shot you know it's all the [ __ ]
that your dad didn't shoot up we didn't
pay for any of this [ __ ] we'd [ __ ]
steal it from our dads but it wasn't
considered stealing really
because your dad didn't care if you took
it or not it's that kind of that kind of
stuff because it was just
cheap stuff laying around there was
stuff left over from hunting expeditions
and [ __ ]
because they go out and get all these
ducks he had a duck machine that once
you clean the ducks you could throw them
in there and it would tumble them and
[ __ ] tear all the feathers off those
dead dead ducks
and you could have a [ __ ] dozens and
dozens of [ __ ] ducks [ __ ] ready to
go
just in a few minutes throwing them to
that thing it's pretty neat
dogs and [ __ ]
and he was he had a nice house like a
two-story house and [ __ ] deck and
everything you know
his dad had a lot of money
but it was just crazy that's the kind of
crazy [ __ ] you did in mississippi
soco is southern comfort by the way
um oh okay
in a minute um they're saying bring out
the [ __ ] 40s and [ __ ] they're in
there chilling
i and i'm gonna bring them out here in a
minute i'm gonna get done with this
i got two
cans a cool 45 they're not 40 ounces i
don't think they're smaller than that
one of them is standard cult 45
and the other one is cult 45 high
gravity which is the deluxe [ __ ]
okay that name cracks me up yeah so i'm
gonna start off with the standard and
i'm gonna tell you what i think
and then when i get done with that if i
can drink it all we'll see we'll see how
i don't know it may not be any good
then i'll go get that high gravity and
i'll drink that
i'll let jenny today some see if she
likes it yeah
but uh like i said i don't remember what
it tasted like before so i'm not gonna
be a big help i don't think
greenspark said i used to make apple pie
shots in the fall using everclear it
tastes just like spicy apple pie yeah
that actually sounds kind of good for
people who don't know whatever clear is
here in the united states
it's the american equivalent of what we
had in brazil called cascasa or pinga
which is pure sugar cane alcohol
but
ever clear here i don't think it's made
with sugar cane it's probably made of
wheat or something grains of some sort
might just be made with sugar
i don't know but it's
190 proof or at least it used to be when
i was a kid it was damn near pure
damn near pure
you could run a brazilian car off of it
because brazil had a special carburation
in their cars and they ran alcohol out
of sugar cane
instead of gasoline they had gasoline
cars but most cars were alcohol
and you could you could take cachaca or
penguin
port right in the tank and [ __ ] it it
run
um
it has no flavor it's like drinking
liquid heat
it's
not pleasant really um well i kind of
feel like uh i remember a thing that a
lot of people did when
when i was a teenager was they would
soak watermelon in everclear yeah and
then eat them like that because i guess
it made the everclear more palatable
like you could get drunk but the
watermelon kind of tasted nice kind of
what we did with it is you just uh make
punch
and if you want a high yield a bunch of
alcoholic drinks
you could just put a can
of everclear in it and it would make all
that [ __ ] punch five gallons of it
[ __ ] strong strong as hell matter of
fact
you really didn't want to pour all the
canned in it maybe like one-third the
can
that's the way that i remember because
if you put the whole can in it
which we did that too but if you put the
whole can in it sometimes you couldn't
drink it
that's how [ __ ]
strong it was
it didn't have a very pleasant it didn't
have much of a taste at all it just
tasted very dry
extremely dry
wasn't very pleasant
effective though and cheap
i think well that's why it's probably
was a thing for so long it's like it
doesn't have to taste good if it [ __ ]
because after
after a few drinks you don't give a [ __ ]
but it tastes like you just want more of
that
the moonshine is similar um shine we're
going to call it shine because that's
what we call shine was actually uh
more pleasant to drink and you could
actually
make shine pretty good
um
some dudes drank it straight
i don't know why you would but
imagine to prove how hardcore you are
imagine you take vodka and you put vodka
on steroids
put that [ __ ] on bull steroids all right
that's that's what a shine is like
but they got companies out there now
making shine that's [ __ ] like gourmet
shine that's got flavors and
you know um well yeah looking pretty
good
well the thing about it is that i mean
the alcohol market is [ __ ] massive
you know it's like there's [ __ ] you'd
buy craft cocktails in bottles now they
got all kind of like artisan beers and
all that kind of stuff which like i said
that's kind of cool it's kind of going
more towards and it's just like food
it's everybody has a more refined
palette now it's like everybody's like
back in the old days you just like
ate or drank whatever you were served
because you didn't know any better but
i mean you know i can understand it
because you know moonshine was like a
uniquely american
so
if you're gonna make moonshine if you're
gonna make an american drink why not do
moonshine it's prohibition era
alcohol
um
it was minimalist back in the day they
were just trying to get the job done but
why not flavor it now that prohibition
is over
flavor it [ __ ] but you can't make it
taste good make it taste good and then
make it
try to keep it in the spirit of
moonshine
okay i said i forgot what they call
those crank out windows somebody said
casement windows i was thinking jealousy
windows
that's the ones that kind of like go out
like that right i thought i don't know
um
no that's something else it's a casement
window i think slasher fred said one of
these days you should uh review the
silent horror classic the cabinet of dr
caligari it's boring i've watched it
it's a boring movie i didn't i didn't
find it boring i like silent movies
actually we should maybe cover some more
of those
visually it's great
yeah it has really good artwork in it
there are the sets the scenes
the makeup um it looks really cool but i
remember it being kind of long and
boring going like come on get to the
point
because
the subject matter isn't very exciting
by today's standards but
i imagine back in the day that movie was
awesome to see well yeah
zach said i found some delicious mint
moose tracks ice cream and oh my god you
guys have to try it that actually does
sound really good because you like most
tricks i mean yeah moose tracks is good
and honestly mint chocolate chip is
probably my favorite i love mint
chocolate chip and i love peppermint ice
cream which you can usually only get
around christmas time maybe get it all
year round nowadays but i kind of feel
like i used to get excited when it was
christmas and i could get peppermint ice
cream i like mint anything to be honest
with you especially like mint chocolate
all of that i love that [ __ ]
um let's see they're talking about
huh john smith said tom's stories make
me wonder how many young men's last
words or watch this that's what i mean
it's just kind of like the whole redneck
thing like here hold my beard and then
like you know
as i said well you know we have the
darwin awards for a reason i don't
really i don't really know how most
dudes even like survive into adulthood
doing [ __ ] like that
you know
oh look at that look he even got
we even found this silver tray
he comes up earlier and he's all excited
he's like look i found this in the
[ __ ] kitchen
[Laughter]
no this is this is
this is in the spirit of my boy
classy [ __ ] is this this you know for
those of you who are not american you
would not know that billy dee williams
was the [ __ ] traditional spokesman
for [ __ ] colt 45 beer i even
downloaded a picture to put up on
instagram later when i put this show up
on it he was epitome of [ __ ] class
and style
and he would go on about in in the
commercials how [ __ ] smooth
how great colt 45 was
so today
will be
my first taste test that is as an adult
a man who has reached maturity and
wisdom i will well i will say
i will
[Laughter]
45.
someday you two will
join with us in the clouds in desperate
city
so we're going to now you got that at
circle k yes that one this one's a
circle you got that at circle k so you
don't get this everywhere
yeah i mean the sir i mean we live like
where we live it's uh it's pretty rural
and we have literally two it's like new
york city with starbucks but with us
it's circle k there's like nothing
nothing nothing farms farms and then
it's circle k here yeah circle k
literally a caddy corner across the
street there's two okay
and then across the street over there is
like publix and pizza place and stuff
mango says wisdom and you're drinking
cult 45 see exactly
exactly oh no we're going to we're going
to look out but look how fancy it looks
like look if you didn't see the can next
to it
you could like to
[Laughter]
call us colt 45 in case you need him as
like a spokesperson or something
your first caucasian sport spokesman
yeah okay we're gonna try this
now i have to [ __ ] um
put this in the context okay
the competition
the competition is [ __ ] budweiser and
and coors and all that okay
it is it is not
it's competing against what we would
call piss water beers the price is the
same
basically so we're gonna see
oh the moment of truth
ah
are you ready to sell out han solo
or what
hold on a second
[Laughter]
that's good is it yeah that's good it's
like a bison try it
it's good like i said i'm not a big beer
it kind of tastes has a dusty dry smell
but uh oh it smells it smells it's not
bad but it's it feels weird yeah just
there's nothing wrong with that
no that's all right there's nothing
wrong with it
no there's nothing wrong with that
no that's all right
it's a lit it was a little weird at
first i was kind of like
like i said i'm not a big beer
connoisseur
but yeah there's no that's a lot better
than budweiser that's actually uh yeah
oh yeah that's a lot better oh yeah i'll
give you that it's like um
it's like a german vicin
the weight is about the same
it's uh not as sweet as a vitamin
but no there's nothing wrong with that
yeah that's actually not bad i don't
know if i would like
drink it all the time but if somebody
had it like i wouldn't be offended or
nothing it's all right you're done wrong
with that
it helps that it's like in the frosty
mug yeah because he prepared for this
[ __ ] yeah that's what i'm saying like if
you're gonna get that excited
about doing this kind of stuff and he's
he comes up and he's all excited he's
like look i found this tray and it's
like i put all the i put the mug in the
freezer and everything like that i'm
like well [ __ ] maybe we should do this
every week that'd be super fun and that
was to try different ones out that was
cheap like it's like a dollar or
something
okay so what's the uh alcohol percentage
on that i can't read it i'm like it's uh
probably a little bit more than beer
5.6 5.6 yep which i don't know how that
thank you victor what do you say girls
drinking beer with little heart eyes
[Laughter]
there's nothing wrong with this this is
[ __ ] decent yeah i mean i've had uh
shittier tasting beers that were like a
lot more expensive than that so
i've had craft beers
that aren't quite that enjoyable
well the thing about craft beers is that
i mean some people really really like
certain flavors and some people don't
like those flavors so i'm just kind of
like there's like a wide variety of
stuff like i said i'm more like a
vanilla chocolate coffee
that kind of thing
um so if you give me something else that
is kind of like a different kind of vibe
i'm probably not going to be down with
it but there yeah that's all right i was
a little weirded out at first like i
smelled it and i was just kind of like
it smells a little dusty doesn't it yeah
it's a little bit smelling something
it's not bad but it's like
odd it's odd
you expect it to be dry and
mango said that's pretty strong for a
beer
5.6
yeah and uh look i gotta say that
that's not it's not bad at all it
doesn't taste cheap
it doesn't taste cheap at all
um it tastes like a decent craft biteson
so my memory was correct i remembered
liking it a lot more up in the barracks
i remembered liking it a lot more than
uh
budweiser and
coors and uh
standard piss water
uh brands of beers and i yeah it stands
it's good
now i don't know
what they did to it to make it taste
that way it's probably artificial i
don't know i don't know
it's a malt liquor
it's probably not brewed but look here's
the deal look at my blind that piss
those piss water beers maybe they're
probably not brewed either it's but yeah
that's [ __ ] that [ __ ] pouring out of
a factory somebody just pissed in a
bottle they piss in a bottle and go here
it is
and then slap a cap on it here you go
suckers no that's decent i'd drink that
yeah that's a surprise that's not bad at
all yeah
i thought it was going to be gross and
it was going to be like a lot of fun but
no no that's actually not bad that's
decent next time we should get budweiser
and then we can [ __ ] on it yeah although
that might be better but it was just
[ __ ] terrible it's a lot better than
bud
try that again maybe you know what we
should do one week one week we should do
like um shitty white sports fans beers
and so we should do like all bud and
coors and stuff like that and we'll see
if they're as bad as we remember
there ain't nothing wrong with it no not
at all
it has a little bit
are y'all gonna think i'm crazy if i say
this it has like a little bit of like a
corn
taste on the back end
is that weird
like almost like popcorn yeah that's
what you're talking about like to me i
don't know if that's like but it tastes
not exactly like popcorn but i can't
really get closer than that
it's like a little bit of popcorn kind
of vibe on the back end which like
that's i'm not mad about it it's decent
that is pretty decent
i would actually probably drink that
again
to be honest with you yeah well you have
to factor in how cheap that was
that was a dollar something
that was the same price no way yeah that
was the same price don't tell me that
i'm gonna be driving up to the [ __ ]
circle
where i got the high gravity next
gravity is supposed to be there would be
like you're the only white girl in lake
county
large was like oh you you taste testing
the [ __ ] yeah yeah but uh that's all
right though there's nothing wrong with
that no
it's probably
probably um the reason why it wasn't
respected is there's something about the
brewing process there's probably
artificial in some way sure
um but hey
who gives a [ __ ] it tastes good and
you're getting [ __ ] drunk off of it
and that is a pretty good
approximation of a of a german veisin
what the germans would call a white beer
yeah not bad it's not bitter
uh it's a smooth
beer it's not sweet
some bisons are a lot sweeter than that
it's like almost drinking like sugary
bread
but it's just like drinking a piece of
bread
which is probably not that
so i don't really know the process it's
it's not beer it's a it's a beer-like
product
there's nothing wrong with that no
that's that's perfectly fine not for the
price no
greenspark says uh lagunitas does a
really great coffee stout see i'm all i
like that kind of stuff um also makes a
great sour cherry beer called cherry
jane that also sounds good uh
kondavatsan says now drink zima you know
what i tried to find it man they didn't
have it i don't think they make it
honestly um i just it's funny because
after we did a show about that or we
talked about it i think we mentioned it
like i have a um subscription on youtube
to a channel that talks about like retro
food and all that kind of stuff and they
put up a video about zima
and i put it in my watch later but i
haven't watched it yet because i was
like oh my god we were just like talking
about that
uh straw 78 said when i was in
antarctica the only beer they had was
this new zealand beer called canterbury
draft
heinous stuff
so you know what they have to sit next
to this
no not this one but the the high uh the
high gravity version
fosters
australians for beer yeah australian
beer
i used to get it in the army when i was
up in egypt
i remember the commercials for that in
like the 90s and uh we liked it we liked
it
i don't think i've ever had fosters i
gotta say though not that i remember
like i said i'm not a big beer person
billy g didn't let me down
well you should call him and say i'll
call billy
[Laughter]
thank you for telling me about colt 45
billy d williams
now who makes that
is it is it bush
do you really think i can see that
miller
do you really think i can see that
uh
yeah i don't know
we might have to like google that yeah
somebody can google it somebody please
google that who makes cult 45 i don't
even think it says on there it's going
to be one of the major manufacturers
it's probably but
yeah you would think because honestly
like everything like all the sodas and
beers and stuff were owned by like two
companies yeah
uh wait a minute ooh
jay what the [ __ ] does that say
heleman heleman
herderman brewing company milwaukee
wisconsin okay so it's its own company
it's g
it looks like heleman man i need better
glasses all right
all right so also it says please recycle
[Laughter]
my verdict on this is uh for
bottom of the barrel
low end price range
this is good
this is good this is real good yeah
that's not bad at all like if i
seriously if i was down in my last two
dollars and just needed some beer like
for whatever reason that's you know no
shame right i'd rather have that than
than uh budweiser
or yeah i would as well would i take
this over yinling no i'd rather take a
yen link well yeah yeah things are more
expensive yeah
um but that's acceptable
uh let's see hold on um
somebody said yeah grantham says zema is
what you fed dumb college girls hoping
it would lead to romance time pretty
much
you know that [ __ ] even back even back
in the day like i tried it because i
kept seeing the commercials and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] i gotta try this out
i told my zima story it's not good it's
not good i told my zima story if you
guys want me to tell the zima story
again i'll tell it again but
i just got back from korea and we saw
zima and [ __ ] i didn't know we were
drinking i almost got my man card
revoked
okay me and another girl
the time time
also got his yeah almost got his man
card yes yeah they took the zima from us
and gave us gin and tonic wind gave us
gin and tonic says drink that i don't
[ __ ] see you drinking that [ __ ]
yeah but what yeah i remember you
telling this story because i laughed you
and i said they they took away your zima
and replaced it with gin and tonic like
that was somehow manlier okay well it
tastes it's a similar taste yeah gin and
tonic yeah gin and tonic that's an old
man drink well like i said but like i
said is that really yeah okay yeah
that's an old man drink you can drink
that
you can drink that and it's it's a
similar flavor
similar it's lemony
clear and lemony
zima is really just
sprite
with malt licorice yeah that's what it
tastes like to me when i tried it gin
and tonic is that basically just with
less sugar that's all yeah i like you
know what i'm every now and then i get
in the mood for gin and tonic but i
think as i've mentioned they're very
good but they're very very sour like so
i can really only drink one or two of
them and then i'm like yeah i gotta move
to something else otherwise i absolutely
will throw up like if i drink more than
two of them
um let's see
zach says are there any lemon-based
baked goods you like i think that's my
other favorite flavor for sweet things
honestly any baked lemon anything lemon
bars lemon cake lemon cake i will eat
any of that stuff key lime pie yummy
yeah i also really like i'm i mean
i got a lemon tree out there growing i
got one lemon off of it so far but
there's 20 or 30 lemons sitting on that
tree
i can't put it in the ground until the
summer's i mean lemon meringue pie i'll
eat that too
holy [ __ ] i like lemon is actually one
of my favorite flavors too i'm really
into mint stuff um i really like
vanilla stuff
but yeah
lemon is good too i like lemon anything
yeah i mean i've had
i've ordered craft beer because
sometimes if we go to like will's pub or
something like that and they have like
different flavors or like the falcon or
something where they don't have a liquor
license although will's pop has a liquor
license now
but you know so i'll try and i was like
what kind of beers you got like what
kind of flavors you got and like
sometimes like some of them are really
good but like i said that hershey's one
that i got like the chocolate one that
was surprisingly good i got like a bunch
of those yeah but
um but i've had some that were
significantly less tasty than that
what's that
you could go up to the falcon
with some of those some of those craft
beers and and put this in the mix and
not tell anybody what it was what it was
they wouldn't know
ooh that would be fun if you did like a
blind taste test let's do a hipster beer
snob yeah blind taste test yeah i'm sure
somebody's done that on the internet
somewhere have they not it's honky
prejudice
there's nothing wrong with that
the beer snobs must not like the [ __ ]
because it it's technically not beer
but it is a beer-like product it's a
beer-like product and uh i'd rather have
this i'm just going to say it again man
i'd rather have that than [ __ ]
budweiser coors or bush or any of the
piss waters
yeah that's true
yeah i don't know it's not as fine as a
[ __ ]
as a stout or a [ __ ] a true german
viking or something but
man for the money no i take that
victor says every time i mention fosters
to australians they remind me that it's
not even sold in australia it's not so
in australia it's an export model yeah
that's what's like well that's what's
funny to me i kind of feel like
i think i've told you guys this before
but one of the funniest things that i've
ever seen
was
uh when
i guess like in germany like i know
cassandra used to be here and she was
like uh from germany so she's tell us
but they have this thing in the grocery
store like ever like in the summer or
whatever and they do like american
products and like some of this stuff is
like okay like it's like okay that's
passable but some of the stuff they like
brand is like american food is like
hilarious
especially like the hot dogs and cans
i'm like we don't we don't do that
we don't do that
but um you know what i mean so
but i just thought that was funny so so
the perception that other countries have
about i just i don't know that always
like that kind of [ __ ] like always
amuses me
uh g
okay g hylamin okay so i couldn't see
the i couldn't see it it's a very very
it's a very condensed font
and
you know i have my glasses on but still
if it's like really small font i still
can't like see all the letters
glenn little said my neighbor pissed
into a wine bottle and gave it to a
friend of ours he sipped it and said
yeah that's strong wine
ew
dude that's nasty
kanavasan says steven seagal's lightning
bolt energy man you know what if we
could find
the steven seagal stuff we would taste a
taste test out on the show too
yeah that's long gone but the thing
about it though is that i think it was
on um
what's that [ __ ] show uh
the guy that does monster madness that
james guy
but they did a show uh and they have he
is another guy that's on there all the
time and he's like a big steven seagal
fan and he actually bought
unopened cans of steven seagal's
energy drinks from i don't even know how
old they were because this video came
out like
just a few years ago and the energy
drinks have been gone since the 90s as
far as i know so he had just bought them
so he like taste tested them on the show
and he's like yeah they kind of tasted
like ass
um victor said do y'all remember putting
jolly ranchers in zimas i remember that
when that was a thing i remember that
was a thing
and
do do do let's see
holy parachute colt 45 introduced by
national brewing company in the spring
of 1963
through a series of mergers and
acquisitions the national brewing
company and its brands are today owned
by the pabst
brewing company
so
okay so technically colt 45 is the same
company that does pbr
because it's pabst right it's pabst okay
it didn't start out as peps but it got
bought out by that company like later on
what is she complaining about every time
you walk up to pookie she's like
she's always doing that kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't know she's yelling at us
um
takes a the tequila beer from the 90s i
remember that i don't i didn't have any
because i don't like tequila but i
remember the commercials for that
and then they're talking about lemon
squares goddamn that sounds good
lemon
louie says keep drinking jenny from when
i remember it gets better
round two
fight
and look he brought a [ __ ] wide glass
he's like well because this is the fancy
fancy
it went all blurry
why did we go blurry i don't know
why did we go blurry there we go
shelby says ooh this is a great idea you
should do a halloween taste test of all
the pumpkin and halloween drinks okay oh
[ __ ] that's a good idea
we probably need to start planning that
like ahead because i always i always
feel like i want to do something really
cool for halloween because it's my very
favorite
but
then like by the time it's like oh like
oh [ __ ] it's like almost halloween and
it's like i just run out of time you
know what i mean but that's actually a
great idea i'm gonna write that down
this is colt 45
high gravity
whatever that means high gravity
lower to the ground it gets you lower to
the ground makes you heavier that's what
we determined yes okay so i'm going to
write it down in here we're going to do
halloween drinks taste test that's a
great effect high gravity
okay it's not
oh it's a little bit darker
okay i got you it's a little bit darker
it is
billy dee don't let me down man well i
don't well i don't think we can blame
billy dee for this if it's not good
because he was only he wasn't around he
wasn't the spokesman
so don't lay this at billy dee's feet no
billy d [ __ ] you did though you did
me right on the first one smell it
be it be fancy
okay swirl it around kinda
[Laughter]
i know that face
wait you like it it's good right
yeah
yeah yeah
smells better
it does actually it doesn't have that
weird
like i said the the smell on coal 45 is
not bad
this doesn't really have it it's very
mild yeah
all right not a huge amount of
difference i will say that there is not
there is but it's not as sweet it's not
as distinctive
it's as the original it's slightly dry
yeah it's slightly drier it's a little
bit more like a [ __ ] darker lager
um almost kind of like a
yin ling
a little bit yeah or uh
sam adams
yeah sam adams yeah uh it's it's heavier
it doesn't
it doesn't have that piss water
consistency it's a little bit heavier
and um it's darker
it's going a little bit it's going away
from whites vyson where the sweeter
elements going more towards a heavier
drier body
like a like a lager
yeah it's good it's definitely drier
it's drier
but it's not like i said it doesn't have
as
forward a flavor yeah as the original
corporate and i'm not saying that colt
45 has a real forward flavor but it
doesn't have the same the smells a lot
better yeah it smells a lot like milder
it's not but like i said it's not as
distinctive of flavor i feel like but
it's good though
almost kind of like uh
almost kind of like a yin ling [ __ ]
black and tan almost
what is it it's called almost maybe
camp guy said coors used to be
considered an exclusive brand because it
was only sold in the rockies president
gerald ford used to drink cores there
you go
what are you doing pookie she's she's
playing with snowman snowman does she is
there enough treats in there is she
getting anything out of there any treats
coming out is there any treats coming
out
there's a big box of treats right there
if you want to refill him she's shaking
her head she's like there's nobody in
there there you go
it's her little snowman
she's like there's treats in there but
she's not hitting it hard enough for
them to come out i guess
john smith said foster is not being sold
in australia it's like when people
discover new castle brown ale isn't made
in newcastle
and straw 78 said it's like hawaiian
pizza i never had pineapple on my pizza
until i left hawaii
we call it hawaiian because it has that
the hawaii doesn't have it yeah well
that yeah like i said i do too there's a
huge fight though it's not my favorite
but i'm not gonna say no i make it all
the time it's good i think it's good and
if you don't have
ham you can use [ __ ] bacon bits yeah
that works too use that too it's very
good that's what i mean it's just i
don't know it's just kind of like to me
the fight between
uh you know thin crust or regular crust
or like deep dish i'm like what why are
we fighting it's all good the daggos are
gonna be like [ __ ] yeah but
pineapple does not belong on a pizza and
i'm gonna say yeah i guess it doesn't it
really doesn't belong on a pizza
but uh when you're having hawaiian pizza
i'm not mad you're not looking at it
that way it's something else does it
just taste good yeah it tastes it just
tastes good i'm not worried about it it
just tastes good now i will say that in
the uk when i was there and this is back
in the 90s and early 2000s i don't know
if you guys are still doing this
nowadays
but i was in i was it wasn't a pizza
place but i was in a grocery store
and they had frozen pizzas and they had
regular ass flavors like you know just
cheese and pepperoni and stuff like that
and then they had one that had
corn niblets
on it
and i'm looking at it going
what the [ __ ] kind of freak puts corn
niblets on a pizza i mean it's not that
weird when you think about it but it's
like i was really weirded out i'm like
brazil he does it a lot yeah i guess and
they'll also put [ __ ] uh peas on it
but brazil didn't invent pizza okay
i mean i guess you could put whatever
you want on there brazil has italians in
it
but the pizza thing was a response to
what was happening in in in the united
states not so much
i mean italy thing
but they they're not bastardized with
the problem with it with brazilian
pizzas that their cooking temperature is
too low it's doughy and it sucks
italians would hate it
real italian pizza is more like focaccia
anyway what we would call focaccia a lot
of times but which man i don't have a
problem with that either that's also
yummy
american pizza i'll eat it all i don't
care
i don't care
it's all good
the worst i've ever heard is japanese
pizza i mean they'll put [ __ ] octopus
ink on a [ __ ] pizza instead of
[ __ ] tomato sauce and they just
they will they will totally bastardize
pizza
it's terrible terrible
i mean the thing about potatoes on a
pizza
yeah
okay no i don't i don't that doesn't
sound like that bad an idea no it
doesn't belong there i mean it'd be
starch on starch yeah but i don't know i
like potatoes but the thing about it is
that
pizza as a concept if you want to like
stretch out and be like well a lot of
cultures have stuff that is obviously
not pizza but it's just we're gonna put
stuff on a bread product like whether
it's
naan or whether it's a tortilla or
whatever the [ __ ] but it's kind of if
you really want to look at it that way
kind of the same thing so i don't know i
just kind of feel like all the
possibilities are open
so i'm not gonna get into the whole
thing it's like is this pizza is this
not pizza i'm like well
does it taste good though if it tastes
good then fine put whatever the [ __ ] you
want on there if it doesn't taste good
then yeah that's a stupid idea you know
that's that's pretty much that's that's
my only
that's my only thing
that's my only thing
i did think the corn on the pizza was
weird though but that was just because
i had never seen that
and like i'm looking at it in the frozen
pizza section i'm like you guys this is
popular enough that people are buying a
frozen pizza
that has corn niblets on it
i was like that's
strange i'm like i'm sure it didn't
taste bad because corn is good but
i don't know it just seemed like a
little bit weird to me that's all camp
guys giving us information about gravity
that might [ __ ] help us so yes i
remember billy beer that was [ __ ]
that was that that came out in the 70s
right like jimmy carter's friends uh
jimmy carter's brother's [ __ ] beer
that's right yeah that but that was
briefly a flash in the band thing
grampher said if you travel the world
the most ubiquitous beer is heineken
it's all over the u.s europe asia and
south africa yeah i've heard that
yeah and honeycomb sucks
never never liked that [ __ ] i don't you
know what i don't know if i've ever had
yeah actually it's a cheap piss water
hiding it's a cheap piss water lager
the
oh well well i gotta say it's it's
better than it's better than coors and
better than
budweiser
but there isn't any difference between
say heineken and fosters
from what i remember about the same
there's nothing special about heineken
yeah like i said i don't think i've ever
had it like
but you know i i was just never a big
beer person yeah
there were there there are american
craft beers that blow heineken away
i've had some really i mean honestly
lately like i said i'm not really yeah
they have really really good american
beers and to be honest it's i'm more
into kind of like i said i like
chocolate beers i like uh you know
coffee stouts i like pumpkin ale i like
all that kind of stuff i like kind of
fall dark kind of flavors i like that
kind of stuff
but yeah you don't want to uh
you don't want to stereotype american
beers by the corporations corp like a
corporations like this okay
we have micro breweries that are pretty
big
doing stuff in local areas you can order
anything anywhere they got some [ __ ]
fantastic american beers but you got
another company
you got to know exactly what it is that
you want to order
it's got to fit you
and what you're looking for there you
know they got guys that are [ __ ]
really into the [ __ ] it's just that you
might not be able to get that at a
national level the united states is
[ __ ] huge
yeah yeah so it might be more like a
luke it might be something more local
right well because what i was saying was
that
um when i was in last year when i went
to st augustine like for a week
they have a it's not a brewery but they
actually make
gin and vodka
and maybe
maybe from i can't remember but they
have like a big like distillery
and they have their own
liquor brands
and you can do like a tour of the you
know the distillery and you can like buy
all their stuff and i was actually gonna
do that but i didn't have time i wasn't
there long enough i went i kind of like
went past it like when i was on the tour
or whatever and i was kind of like oh i
need to come back here and like buy some
stuff because it'd be really cool to
like get some liquor that was like
made locally i mean st augustine is what
like 50 miles from here so i was like oh
i want to taste some like some gin and
some vodka that was just made like right
there i thought that would be really
cool but i just didn't have time to do
it but like maybe next time i go i'll do
it but i just thought that was kind of
like awesome that they do that so like i
said it's not even like a brewery
okay so um
colt
an acceptable product
within its price range
competitive for as cheap as that is
you're right yeah i mean how much was
the high gravity oh like a dollar thirty
three or something like that not bad at
all yeah i've paid more than that for
coffee drinks of that size so
nothing wrong with that at all
i think you know what i think i like the
original one better though
the original one is more like a video if
you guys are [ __ ] beer snobs this one
is more like a
like a decent brown ale
yeah or
like a lager that one's good too but
it's not it doesn't like um
it's not like i said it's not as
distinctive yeah it it ends up like the
first one like had kind of a distinctive
flavor that one was kind of like good
but it's like all the rest of them
generic like yeah i've had other ones
that tasted like that it's good but it's
not like anything this is what you want
to drink if you want a drink of cold 45
that's kind of like a like a like a sam
adams
okay that's right it would
be you know
that's cheaper than sam adams though
uh yeah
but uh well at least we know that if we
ever like get a hankering then there you
go like hey we need some beer
because every now and then
like we're walking around sam's to the
grocery store like let's get like a
little just we usually just buy a little
six pack i don't ever buy like a big
huge thing but
sometimes i'll get because like i said
i'm not a big beer person we're more
we're more vodka rum tequila
kind of people
but yeah there's nothing wrong with that
we live in a land of plenty
where even the very poor can get their
hands on some decent [ __ ] that's decent
but you know what that kind of makes me
happy though because i was thinking
that that [ __ ] was gonna be like swell
no
and it's not it's it's pretty good yeah
it's pretty good that's pretty good and
especially like as cheap as this i'm
like well that makes me happy that at
least people that only have like a buck
and they're like look i just want some
goddamn beer yeah at least you get
something that's like halfway drinkable
yeah yeah jesus christ oh i'd much
rather have that like i said than
[ __ ] standard budweiser coors or
michelob or that [ __ ] crap
that's that's a much better flavor
that tastes like a higher end beer
it it does it does actually i'm gonna
i'm gonna give it that much the only
reason why it's cheaper is the way that
they're producing that is not the way
you do a traditional beer so
but the consumer of this doesn't care
about the manufacturing process whether
it's traditional or like i said does it
just want does it taste good
yeah
and is it like cost-effective it's just
yeah they're making they're able to
replicate replicate a higher end beer
using
technologies and still keep the price
low nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with that
so i'm saying look look my broke ass
if i just have a dollar or two and i
just want to get it yeah i've been
drinking that there's nothing wrong with
that at all right that kind of like
gives me hope for the future and you got
two selections you can have something
like a bison or something more kind of
like a lager yeah yeah well and we've
talked about this before like in not so
much in relation to alcohol but in
relation to food
is that
i kind of feel like back in the day
because we grew up in like the 70s and
stuff like that but back in the day like
you know there wasn't a lot of
choice
so you just kind of and people didn't
have like real refined palettes they
didn't really we didn't have the
internet you didn't know
about
all of this other kind of like uh food
around the world and [ __ ] like that so
people weren't as sophisticated so i
kind of feel like they could just like
feed you whatever [ __ ] sweat the you
know you would just like take it and you
just be like yeah this is good because
you hadn't really you didn't have
anything to compare it to yeah whereas
nowadays
uh thankfully you can't really get away
with that anymore like you try to like
pass off some like
shitty like subpar kind of crap doesn't
work now and nowadays people be like nah
yeah you can get like way better [ __ ]
than that for the same price and they're
not gonna like stand for it which like i
said i think that's better i think
that's good i think that's good in the
case of colt
col of course from the very from the
very beginning of a cult it was a black
clientele that's who that's who was
buying
i see why they were buying okay if the
original and the original cult that i
drank
tasted like the way i remembered it
basically in in the early 90s
and it was probably tasted that way in
the 70s too
which if you have a limited income
that's the way i would definitely go
oh yeah
um
but no
so
the buyer of today
african-american
and uh
does something like this have a place in
today's market
could you get a beer that tastes like
that for that price
probably not at your local
corner store
in a city in in an urban environment
so yeah
you'd get this
it makes perfect sense this is what you
would get
i'm trying to think of anything for
around a dollar 33
that tastes like that
and i don't think so
yeah maybe not i mean
so that's what you would buy
and you have a generational
clientele
people growing up on that people's dads
drinking that
so yeah that's why that exists but it
makes sense that that's a that's a good
product
for like a dollar thirty-something hell
yeah i mean you can't beat that
like i said i've had eight dollars that
didn't yeah
we've spent
we spent a [ __ ] four or five dollars
on beers and [ __ ] clubs
that are about like this
well hell a couple times i've spent
seven eight dollars on one of those
canned cocktails yeah that was like that
tasted like ass you're compared to that
right do you remember that one i got the
other day i can't remember what flavor
it was it sounded good in theory
and i can't remember what i know there
was cucumber in it and i love cucumbers
i got it was cucumber and something
and i was like oh that sounds kind of
good and it was like a canned cocktail
so i got it and it was
awful
man that tasted so good like i drank it
because i was like well i paid for it so
i might as well but
man it was not good yeah
ugh
maybe other people might like it but i
was just kind of like yeah no it's not
good not good now i gotta try a
hurricane
that might be the next thing maybe
that'll be next friday [ __ ] yeah like i
said maybe this should be a recurring
thing like i said we don't have to talk
about in the whole show but it might be
interesting to
kind of go and like try out all these
weird
that sounds like well they're only weird
to us
no that would be
now that i've had that
thought about it [ __ ] tasted both of
them put myself in the shoes of the
customer
that would be the king of the hood
you know what i'm talking about yeah
it's been around forever your dad drank
it your granddad drank it probably and
you're like oh yeah you know so there's
a heritage behind it and uh
the price was low and drank it and huh
no that's that's good well the thing
about it too is that i think
sometimes sometimes what happens with
some particular products
is they get associated with a particular
demographic exactly that's what happens
and so then everybody associates them
with that it's like well i don't want
any of that because that's associated
with that right that's some people that
aren't like that
they're not like me yeah yeah but then
like you drink there's no difference
between that and like some [ __ ]
hipster beer that i've drunk like a
[ __ ]
bar you know what i mean it's like
there's no difference it doesn't taste
any different so it's like i it's all
perception it's awesome
liquor you can make it faster and
cheaper
but the quality is the quality in terms
of taste the quality is good okay it's a
sanitary product and the taste is
[ __ ] great it's good
the only thing price wise that would be
equivalent would be bottom end lager
bud coors
michelob [ __ ] like that
i'd rather have that
i would as well so there you go be
honest with you so that's going to rule
the hood right there
like i said so i understand i want to go
i want to go back and taste kate cobra
because when i had that
i liked king
yeah but i can't find it you can't find
it like i said i don't know if they make
that anymore maybe no they make it and
they do that yeah it's all modern and
everything and the cobras more [ __ ]
stylized on it
they got
they got it they just don't sell it here
cuomo says folks who don't like
pineapple pizza and who don't like candy
corn and who don't like mint chocolate
always have to remind people how against
it they are yes i have noticed this i
have noticed this also people who don't
like
coconut that is another thing that uh
people who don't like coconuts seem
really kind of like defensive
about how they don't like coconut yeah
which
like whatever you can like and don't
like what you listen to it really
doesn't make this no never mind to me
it's like i'm not you it's like you do
whatever you're doing
but
i don't get this whole argument about
it's like oh well oh mint chocolate it's
the devil or hawaiian pizza instead of
like shut the [ __ ] up like some people
like it's food get the [ __ ] over it some
people like it and some people don't
that's how the world works
let's i know that some of it is done for
like dramatic effect i get that but you
know in a way like at the end of the day
it's just dumb it's a dumb thing to
argue drink that and [ __ ] think
dollar 33
that's what i mean
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
this is good i mean i it's good that
we're we're doing this now because you
know in the future in case i ever become
homeless right there you go yeah
and i i have like a two and i just like
all know what to get yeah
so yeah right yeah this is my helmet
that's that's not bad at all i will say
i jumped into circle k and probably get
that out of the selection that they had
at circle k i will say
i like
the original court for colt 45 better
yeah i think i think it's sweet um
because i do like the kind of corny
flavor that it has i don't know if it's
corn but it just tastes it tasted like
that to me yeah and it had that vice in
front end right but that's good too yeah
but that's good too that's more like a
[ __ ] higher end logger sure
there's nothing wrong with that as [ __ ]
at all i mean to be honest here's the
thing
i'm not gonna [ __ ] on circle k because
even though like i said sandwiches you
guys yeah and that's what i was just
gonna say you knew where i was going
with that he knew where i was going with
that
we've been together a long time he knows
where i'm going with that so uh so yeah
as i said we live where we live it's
lake county
it's very it's rural okay was it like
the where we live is kind of like you
know a neighborhood there's like big
houses and stuff but most of the [ __ ]
around here is like farmland cows
blueberries blah blah
now we have
what is it like a mile up the street i
think it's a mile up the street
circle k on one side gas station
convenience store there's subway in
there i think and then literally across
the street caddy corner is another
circle k now across the street over
there is like a publix and
like there's a dominoes and a japanese
restaurant and a breakfast place and
like or like a brunch place or something
like that so there's all this kind of
stuff going on over there and there's a
hair salon too i think
so
a lot of times when we are out at the
club
and
i don't know why i get so excited about
this but we're like coming back from the
club and now that we live out here kind
of a little bit in the middle of nowhere
so when we come back from the club we're
taking the uh the toll roads
and so we don't pass anything like where
we used to live
uh you'd pass
you know mcdonald's and ihop and like
all this other kind of stuff that was
open all night so it's like if you were
drunk and you wanted some pancakes or an
egg mcmuffin or something you could like
stop and get that but where we live now
there's really nothing on the way
so most of the time if we're hungry on
the way home from the bar it's like well
we got to go to circle k and see what
they have like in the deli section or in
the whatever
so we usually go in there and see what
their selection of sandwiches is now tom
will get like some micro burritos but
i'm just kind of like man i don't really
want to do that because i know i'll be
regretting it the next day so i usually
just get a sandwich and i will be honest
with you and i think this is kind of
goes along with a lot of stuff where i
know that people would like [ __ ] on like
convenience store sandwiches and stuff
back in the old days but they've really
kind of like upped their game
honestly i have been to the circle k i
usually will get and i know this is
probably like inadvisable usually but i
usually get they have a really nice
chicken salad with cranberries like a
cold sandwich and that [ __ ] is actually
pretty good and like all the bread is
like always really soft and everything
like that it's like actually pretty
delicious so i usually get one of those
in like a little bag of like some
cheddar chips or something like that
like on the way home they got cuban
sandwiches too like you gotta
you gotta like mitigate your kind of
[ __ ] expectations because we usually
go there like two three in the morning
and a lot of their shit's gone so you
kind of gotta pick through what they got
left but even the stuff that's left
it's pretty good i've even got like an
egg salad there before again i know not
advisable but
[ __ ] was good bread was all soft and
pillowy
just nice they have nice [ __ ] in there
so let me go make a drink here you know
what i mean so it's just kind of like
convenience stores just like everything
else have had to like up their game and
they know that like our drunk asses are
gonna be
rolling in there
at three o'clock in the morning and tom
will come in there because you know how
tom is and he'll come in there and be
like what kind of sandwiches you got
what sandwiches are left you know what i
mean
and uh you know
but like i said he usually ends up
getting burritos and then microwaves
when we get home but it's like i don't
want that i just always want
i don't know when i get drunk i usually
like i like egg things i like i like
things with eggs in it i want to omelet
or
i like breakfasty kind of stuff or
that's why i usually end up getting
something cold
i don't really want something like a
burrito it's like spicy because i'm like
yeah that's gonna cause problems
tomorrow i've i've been there before so
i usually try to get something like cold
egg salad or like i said they have a
delightful chicken salad that has
cranberries in it that is very good but
they don't always have them like
sometimes they're all gone but sometimes
sometimes they have them and they're
actually like quite good quite good
uh let's see i kind of got behind on the
comments
grampar says how come the brand of beer
you drink meshes with the music you want
to hear
yeah that's what i mean i kind of feel
like
if you kind of
you know
stepped back and looked at the whole
thing i kind of feel like there's not
enough difference between
that's what i mean it's like all
perception it's all perception
because there's really not a great deal
of difference between
the taste of that for example
and the taste of like some like high-end
kind of like craft beer or whatever and
i've had some craft beers that kind of
tasted comparable to that
and then like but there's whole
subcultures
around man different kind of beer and
[ __ ] like that sly just showed up
i don't know if you were here i didn't
see you commenting earlier i did a
[ __ ] cold 45 taste test did regular
coat then i did high gravity all right
you can go back and watch it later i
didn't see your comments on there i was
talking and i was saying that brothers
up in the barracks they're [ __ ]
buying coal they're buying king cobra
and they were buying he's actually army
he's a black dude from the army too
they were buying king cobra colt
uh [ __ ] old english they'd get that
one and they would uh what was the other
one
schlitz malt liquor bull
all the malt liquors
white boys wanted to [ __ ] revolt my
white car behind drinking that [ __ ] but
they would [ __ ] buy it and
and i drank the [ __ ] and i will i will
attest
out of the [ __ ] lower end beers
i'd rather have that malt liquor
it was i would as well yeah i'm gonna
get that right much better than
budweiser core bush
although like i said i think that it
would be like let's not spend a lot of
money on it because we don't have a lot
of money but i think it would be funny
to do
a bro bro that's what we'll call it
the bro brew
taste test
challenge
and we'll get like all the kind of bro
beers like the budweiser and all that
kind of stuff which i don't love
but
like i said let's not spend a lot of
money right but we'll just get like a
can each yeah so sly what i was saying
was as i was saying that billy deed was
was right
okay
if you're buying beer out of a [ __ ]
lit out of a [ __ ] corner store
you're not going to find a [ __ ] fine
craft beer there you're going to find
[ __ ] piss water and yeah circle k a
certain circle or a 7-11 or whatever and
from based on what i have the two
it's just like i remembered back in the
early 90s
yeah that coat was [ __ ] good
pretty good
it's like a nice bison beer with like a
german white beer
and then the um
the high gravity which is supposed to be
the fancier [ __ ] was like a decent lager
uh but uh
it was heavier
had a nice [ __ ] flavor to it it was
good good beer it's like a lovely
bouquet they're they're somehow
using the malt liquor process they are
be they're able to
reproduce the
reproduce the experience of drinking of
drinking a higher end craft beer at a
lower price
so i'd say billy dee was saying was
telling you the truth they were like
buy this at your local quarter store
it's better than the other [ __ ] this may
not be it
may not be beer
but it's a beer-like product and it's
better than the other [ __ ] sure so
staying within the budget zach says i
work at a get-go which is basically poor
man circle k
i cook the food which is nasty even by
fast food standards i always go for the
deli sandwiches for lunch yeah i mean to
be honest
i've had i've eaten many sandwiches and
things like
like that from convenience stores and i
haven't really had any problems
i don't get the heated up food i don't
do that but like sometimes they have
well in 7-eleven really kind of upped
their game because i used to get [ __ ]
from 7-eleven all the time because there
was one next door to where i worked when
i worked at the print shop so when i
forgot to bring lunch i would always go
over there and get something and they
actually had like they had little like
almost like little charcuterie plates
where it would have kind of like little
meat and cheese and nuts and stuff like
that you could buy that you could buy
apples and bananas and all that kind of
[ __ ] in there you could bet all that
kind of stuff hugo said this episode
should be sponsored by circle k sure
yeah hey circle okay call us up hey man
there's two of them like right there
they're breakfast sandwiches at [ __ ]
three o'clock in the morning [ __ ] if
they're still there that's what i mean
that chicken salad with cranberries that
is [ __ ] delicious i'm gonna go that
it's good
i mean things are a foot at the circle i
mean i'm drunk yeah but
you know i'll give it that but like that
it's a good thing and they got [ __ ]
ribs there they got [ __ ] mcribs but
the thing is they don't call it a mcrib
well
you take it home
disassemble it
you want to take the ribs and put the
ribs in the microwave put a little bit
of barbecue sauce on it you always got
barbecue i got barbecue it's the hot
barbecue sauce at the house
toast to the bun
and it should all be the buns put them
in your toaster and it should all be
done quickly and then you [ __ ] pop
that [ __ ] back out
put the [ __ ]
toasted buns on your [ __ ] plate put
the [ __ ] mcrib on there that's
already got the hot barbecue sauce
because you just microwaved it throw the
cold pickles back on you want to
separate that
take it back up get crawl into bed with
your woman and [ __ ] eat that [ __ ]
[ __ ] well watching we'll be in bed
we'll be in bed
drunk
nude and [ __ ] big ass boobs [ __ ]
flopping i'ma [ __ ] try to get that
[ __ ] i've been trying to get this [ __ ]
cheap for [ __ ] two or three days now
she's running
she's running from me i'm trying to get
laid i wait wake up this morning and i
was like mama get some mention she's
like that i got in and everything but
then she's like i'm too tired i wanted
and then i lost interest and then she
runs off
well dude it was like time for me to get
up i got it i got work to do i'm trying
to get laid plus it's kind of hot though
i understand and i've been in there i'd
actually been awake i've been awake
since 4 30. i will give it like 4 or 4
30 because one pookie was running up and
down like a buffalo herd and two i had
to pee so then like i got up and i went
down the hall of the bathroom and then i
got back in then pookie comes up like
hey mama what are you doing i'm like hey
sweetie what are you doing and then i
was like okay i'm gonna try to go back
to sleep and then i was like [ __ ] me and
you're still like laying there with no
like and i couldn't go back to sleep so
i laid there for like two or three hours
then i finally fell back to sleep i
think at like 6 a.m
and then tom comes back in here and he's
like hey what's going on and i was like
oh gee oh man i just fell back to sleep
and you whip me back up um that is rad's
library oh my god i love your channel
well thank you very much
uh new to your channel love your blue
hair well thank you very much who said
that
bad as rad's library okay thank you so
it's a new person thank you very much
new person
like
hi what are you doing like yeah saying
slides talking about how he didn't drink
till he got to korea slander
served in korea when we were in the army
which is a forgotten war and this korea
is called the forgotten war and it's
still going on today even though it
wasn't like it was back in the day
but sly is a little bit older than me i
think he's 61.
but yeah i think he said that earlier
yeah we're from the same culture though
he knows what i'm talking about
and uh this you weren't here slices he's
been sick he's under the weather a
couple days back i was told stories
about the barracks and us fighting over
beer remember the barracks parties where
you boys go out and buy all this [ __ ]
mad dog 2020 and [ __ ] all these cheap
ass beers because your kids you bring it
back and you give it out to all your
friends and [ __ ] let's do a mad dog 2020
show you can do that yeah
yeah we'll get that dog we'll get some
good flavors mad dog is actually really
good that's what i'm saying we'll get i
i would like like some strawberry yeah i
would like some strawberries yeah it'll
get you [ __ ] up and it tastes like
melted [ __ ] otter pops that's
something
yeah so by the end of the show we'll
probably be like incoherent and that'd
be super fun don't worry about the
high-minded [ __ ] alcohol of love well
that's been aged in an oak barrel for
their now well well the thing about it
it's all well it's all what do you want
to achieve
what do you want to achieve if you just
want to get like [ __ ] up with
something that like tastes decent yeah
then at least fun or it is at least fun
yeah like if you're gonna like sit there
and like enjoy it like i'm not gonna
drink that much of it i'm not gonna get
drunk on it or anything like that but
it's just like i just want to enjoy the
taste then yeah that's a whole other
thing i'm across the board i can drink
the glen living glenfiddich [ __ ] well
me too it's like it goes like i said it
depends on what you're entering it's all
what you're in what your end goal is
what is your angle yeah you know do you
just want to get as [ __ ] up like as
cheaply as possible then you know you
can be accommodated
but if you don't want to get drunk you
just want that right a little bit of a
buzz but you want it to like taste good
that's like that's a whole different
situation yeah so sly today was colt 45
taste test i was trying to get king
cobra and [ __ ] schlitz malt liquor
bowl but they don't sell it around here
yeah we got to go i got to go to the
hood tom went all over the place
he was gone for hours and hours so i was
only had access to [ __ ] cracker
liquor stores and [ __ ] out here out
here with the country crackers the only
thing you're gonna find is colt 45
and and hurricane hurricane's famous
here too that's the younger generation
though right
a younger generation of black people
will [ __ ] drink a hurricane that'll
be another show
but i was looking for the classics
1990s classics that's king cobra okay
because cold 45 70s
okay like i said i remember yeah that
was seven all that [ __ ] right that's all
that [ __ ] and um today
billy d spokesman of cult 45 delivered
and uh thinking back over to the
over over the uh advertisement
within its price range
billy d wasn't lying
if you're buying out of a corner store
like
a circle k or 7-eleven
for the price
king cobra already [ __ ] coal 45 and
the malt liquors
would uh give you kind of a better
higher end experience
versus say
piss water
lager like bush or
or
budweiser you know you want to go for
the
you want to go first you know
colt
yeah colt would be
that's that's the granddaddy of them
that's been around for a long long time
it's a little heavier body
a little more mild
uh high alcohol content i mean i'm
pretty [ __ ] up i drink [ __ ] what i
drink two of them well yeah but you also
had right that right so that wasn't the
beer that did that
and um malt liquor technology does have
brewing analogues
yeah i would say
standard colt 45 is very much like a
german bison and uh
coal 45 high density would be like a
like a good lager
yeah
now
they're not made like beers they're made
a lot faster but as a end user
of the product
you won't know the difference
it's [ __ ]
you won't know the difference when
you're drinking it you you're talking
about
it's snobbery in a certain way although
i do understand craftsmanship you know i
respect that i mean there is something
to be said right yeah for
right but like i said it depends on the
context it's just like pretty much
everything else in life
if i only had a dollar fifty in my
pocket and i wanted a [ __ ] good beer
like drink i'd go for something like
coke sure
it'd be better than a dollar fifty worth
of [ __ ] that's what i mean you just
have to like manage your expert like
what what do i want to achieve
how much do i have to achieve that
achieve that right and what is the best
possible experience that i could
purchase right with the little amount of
work that i have and that's basically
what billy d's sales pitch was well
that's the entire that's kind of like so
that's the entire that's kind of like my
entire life right yeah to be honest
right
and uh from kind of like entire life
from what i experienced it's a high
quality product and [ __ ] safe yeah no
like i said not bad at all not bad at
all there's nothing wrong with it yukon
cornelius 81 do you lick your pickaxe
because i just want to know about that
uh finally cut a live for the first time
in two years go ahead um i was 101st in
the 2000s okay what unit what what what
regiment uh 9 101 abn we used to get
[ __ ] facing 9101
he's in the chopper units thank you very
much what do you say we used to get
shit-faced and repel off oops yeah uh
off the fourth floor of the barracks
okay yeah yeah yeah sergeant major made
it go dry for a bit yeah yeah
yeah we used to repel all the time we
were doing aussie aussie repel and
[ __ ] swiss all the time you should
have been on the mfo mission if you were
in the infantry units you'd have been on
mfo with us [ __ ] in egypt you would
have [ __ ] loved it man i got pictures
of myself going [ __ ] aussie all
[ __ ] day off our [ __ ] jump tower
[ __ ] uh at south cap and it was
because nobody else wanted to do it man
everybody did their mandatory minimum
[ __ ] two little repels and then the
[ __ ] guys at the top [ __ ] repel
masters just like anybody want to do it
again and [ __ ] i was up there all day
doing aussies
flying aussies [ __ ] jumping out and
everything i [ __ ] love this [ __ ] i
wish i was
what happened was is that
back in the 90s i was we're we were in
during this one of the best parts to be
in the army it was a strong army we had
lots of money
and then all of a sudden they wanted to
downsize [ __ ] clinton got in and they
were like well these kind of armies are
out of date which there's something to
be said to that in in a certain way
but uh i was lucky to get out with an
honorable discharge in 94. they were
kicking out everybody for any old
[ __ ] reason
um and then i had my motorcycle wrecked
and uh ended up picking up a [ __ ]
good profile
and uh got my retirement that way but
i went back connor and did some some
contracting stuff later on after 9 11
and
man i you know i always miss it it's in
me
i came up in a military
school even before i went in you know
but
uh the empire is not in good condition
and then you know i don't want to get
doing it i don't want to go down that
[ __ ] path i'm gonna go to the rest
come back a second gramps says in oregon
we would ask bartenders to put a dribble
of tomato juice in the beer red beer is
big out west i've heard of that but i've
never
had it like to me just i mean it sounds
gross but then i think about it i'm like
well yeah but i drink bloody marys like
i love bloody marys and that's tomato
juice obviously so
i don't see how it would be any weirder
so i you know i don't know
because at first like when i first heard
about clamato i was like ew but then
when i thought about it i was like wait
what am i oohing about that would
probably be delicious i don't know
zack says i have sheets gas stations
near me i've heard of those but we don't
have those in florida as far as i know
or we don't have them around here
uh they're practically on every corner
their food is gross but good at 3am when
you're drunk yeah i mean
i to be fair
i've never had
a circle k sandwich sober
no that's not true that's not true
because the last time i think the
not the last time but the time before
that we went out to barbarella
uh and i think we talked about this on
the show before
tom got
epically [ __ ] up i mean i haven't seen
him like that and they don't even sell
like liquor in there we didn't bring any
liquor because we've talked about it's
like oh maybe we should bring some booze
because we have booze at home it's like
maybe we should bring someone like put
in the trunk and we'll like [ __ ] carp
but like you know do the [ __ ] uh
tailgate or whatever
but we never did it we're too lazy
so
he had
i had literally like the whole night we
were there we got there right when they
opened which is like at 9 30. i had one
drink then and it was just kind of like
a one of those like [ __ ] you know
just
malt liquor like beer cocktails or
whatever so four or five percent alcohol
i had one of those at like 9 30 at
another one at 10 30 and then i drink
anything else the rest of the night i
just drank water
so we were there for hours and hours i
think we were there until 2 or 2 15 or
something like that
and so when we left i was completely
sober and tom was completely shit-faced
would you talk about it so that that
time that we went that you got like suit
that i had to draw and i was wrecking
the car in the parking lot that's yeah
yeah so he was completely shippy that
was fun so i was so i was sober so i
will so i said that i've never had like
a circle k sandwich like uh sober but
that is not true because i was actually
sober that night i had not had a drink
in like four or five hours by the time
that we left because i just i had two
and then i was like man i don't really
want anymore and i was like dancing and
i was having a good time and i was just
kind of like yeah so i just drank water
like the rest from 10 30 from until two
so when we left i mean thankfully
i was sober because
everybody i don't know if you know this
but when we were leaving
um a couple of our friends were like
you're not driving right like they said
to you and i don't know if you remember
that no i don't remember he doesn't
remember and i was like
oh boy
and then like he's in the car and i'm
just kind of like oh my god i was like
get out get out
so it was like that i just drove she
kicked me out i did i kicked you out
yeah we pulled over in the parking lot
and i was like get the [ __ ] out of this
car i'm driving it says man my cousin
drink maggi mad dog 2020 we were talking
about that earlier
he said he misses us we miss you too
slide
yeah we haven't seen you in a long time
yeah we haven't seen you in a long time
um then he goes on later on and goes oh
thank you victor
i forgot i totally missed that i was way
behind can you put grits on pizza no you
can but i wouldn't but
should you no
no but should you no that wouldn't work
out right
that's a funny that's a funny question
though you know i know you're [ __ ]
with us
grits are like polenta
let's think about it
though like is there any application no
where it could work like not obviously
like not it would have to be like dry no
vic no now victor i don't know exactly i
don't really know exactly your [ __ ]
ethnic background
but grits
can be seasoned to match any ethnic
cuisine
like i could do mexican grits
it's corn okay well that's what i mean
it's not i know a lot of people like to
talk about grits like oh it's this big
southern thing but no but they're just
like a blank canvas
just like polenta or bread or rice or
anything like that you can do pretty
much anything with grits that you can
get i can get together with carnavasalan
who lives in who lives in tijuana and me
and him here we trade recipes a lot
where we're trading recipes of
uh of girls doing recipes and stuff
online
because we both love [ __ ] food
i could me and him can get together and
[ __ ] um
combine our [ __ ] minds and make
mexican grits that's how good grits are
they're cheap they last forever they
come in [ __ ] big old things it's kind
of like masa like when you're making it
yeah it's similar it's like making mega
masa like tortilla masa
uh it's
the grits were are made of [ __ ]
hominy they're harmony grits which
that's you take
corn
cattle
quality corn cracked corn that's hard
corn you put it in a 55 gallon [ __ ]
drum and put lye in it and it blows up
like wet popcorn
then you pull that out of it and you
blend it into little tiny pieces and
then you dry it
and it will stay forever
put it in the hot water
it'll come right back into kind of like
a porridge or like a
like a polenta or like a
a corn flavored
what's a good way to put it like a like
a corn flavored
mashed potatoes it's kind of what it's
like think of it as like corn flavored
mashed potatoes yeah i mean pretty much
anything you could do with any kind of
like starch like that you can do with
gritsy as well it's not it doesn't have
a real strong flavor and then you can
add anything to that season wise
seasoning cheese
[ __ ] meat
vegetables some weirdos make it sweet
too maybe you can make it sweet or you
can make it salty i don't do that but i
know some people did you right i'm not
hating the south got through the civil
war and all those embargoes because of
damn grits
yeah
that went on for a couple years but
grits had grits was a survival [ __ ]
food
for southerners and it didn't matter the
color white or black they were eating
that it's kind of like our version of an
mre
and you can do [ __ ] beautiful dishes
bowl
what i like what's standard here
a big bowl of grits
with salt and pepper cajun seasoning
butter in it
bacon bits
cheese
and diced up peppers like bell peppers
red peppers green peppers whatever i
like them with boiled eggs in them with
heart with like and you line that [ __ ]
with hard-boiled eggs around it yeah
it's good you take a spoon and you cut a
piece of egg off and then get some grits
and eat them
yeah
and it's kind of thick
like a thick porridge or mashed potatoes
i like mad potatoes not quite that thick
but
michael shaffer said just like the old
days tom goes on a grit rant [ __ ] all
this [ __ ]
yeah yeah john gore says fruit loops on
pizza
no
no now they do have dessert pizzas but i
will say very different look i made all
kind of like sugary cereals and stuff
froot loops can die in a fire like look
i'm not [ __ ] on you if you like
fruit loops i do not like fruit loops
i've never launched fruit loops if i'm
gonna do sugary cereal
i'm gonna do um
what are the like frosted mini wheats
yeah or honey bunches of oats okay look
or remember back back in the old days
they used to have waffles yeah do you
guys remember waffles maybe yeah
that
your generic
dessert pizza is a pizza crust with some
kind of pie filling sure
usually if that works it's just i mean
it's just usually a fruit pie filling
and then on top of that
um basically uh
creamer yeah captain crunch is good too
coffee creamer you mix some
water in with a coffee creamer maybe
like some
some kind of seasoning maybe some sugar
or something and you [ __ ] spoon that
on top instead of cheese and then you
bake it that's the very very basic
is that good yeah yeah like it's as good
as a pop-tart because what you're making
is a pop-tart and [ __ ] man nothing wrong
with pop-tarts yeah actually it's a high
class it's about as high class as colt
45 yeah okay
but like i said earlier
are we being snobby about that we're
being snobby because look i'm not gonna
be snobby i like pop tarts too yeah we
talked about this before bought a case
of pop-tarts i got we have pop-tarts
downstairs right now he got a whole case
of them at sands although i'm kind of
well i don't know if i'd say snobby but
it's not snobbery it's just that i tend
to prefer
some flavors over others honestly the
strawberry ones with the multicolored
sprinkles those are the best ones yeah
but
the cinnamon ones are good too
the chocolate ones are okay
um but a lot of the other ones i don't
really have time for to be honest with
you don't really have time for it honky
snobbery sometimes [ __ ] factors into
a lot of [ __ ]
especially with the college crowd those
[ __ ] will [ __ ] get up in there and
they'll [ __ ] worry about all kinds of
you know micro brewery issues when it
comes to beer
and corner stores the liquor stores that
colt 45 [ __ ] standard was pretty good
it was like a decent bison
um i would drink that or the high the
high gravity was good too
but it was like a decent life yeah i
liked the original better but that was
good too i wouldn't i wouldn't be mad
very much uh punching above
the uh competition when it came to price
sure
so out of the cheap beers i'd rather
have coal
i don't drink cheap beers though that's
the difference but if i was going to
drink cheap beers i'd drink coke
just say
yeah they're talking about captain
crunch yeah i that's another one i
forgot captain crunch is also delicious
i'm not super into the crunch berries
i'll eat them i'm not like a snob about
it but the peanut butter captain crunch
is good but honestly i like the og i
like the og captain crunch that's also
very good
anybody remember nut and honey yeah
i remember that
uh sly says sugar pops when i'm very
hungry yeah i don't
and honestly i love sweet [ __ ] sugar
pops are a little sweet for me a little
sweet right
oh you know do you guys remember cookie
crisp yeah
did they still make that yeah those were
delicious they had like three different
flavors of cookie crisp well again like
the original like chocolate chip flavor
oh man those were so good i don't even
know if they make those anymore i don't
we don't buy like a lot of cereal so i
don't really know but
yeah man i was i used to really like
cookie crisps i honestly though i really
wish
my favorite cereal from when i was a kid
other than frosted mini wheats
which i'll still eat to this day because
that's just delicious but
was waffles
man waffles were so good and i kind of
feel like they don't make i'm sure they
make a comparable cereal nowadays cause
there's like a million different ones
but i kind of miss waffles man those are
slides just saying just [ __ ] salt and
butter on grits that's the old school
that's the old school way
honestly i just yeah i just like salt
pepper butter i mean but it's good with
hard-boiled eggs in it too yeah i could
take or leave bacon bits that's good in
it or it's not good i don't really care
yukon cornelius says tom we supported
aerosol entry units 5-0 deuce and 506
mostly
we did uh training missions stateside
combat missions in iraq
he was a uh-60 true crew chief gunner it
was usually a good time okay yeah
i was in for when i was in the 101st i
remember
i was in the first and the three to
seventh and first and three two seven
recomplitute
i was also in the 506 but i was in the
506 when it was attached to second id up
in korea on the dmz
i was in i was a place called camp
greaves
which we were kind of like their dmz
police our alpha company was liberty
bill
and we had guys that [ __ ] we were
like close associates with joint jsa
joint security area
now um
um
my uncle
was at 101st task force 160. that's a
lot special operations at aviation
and he's doing all kinds of high-speed
[ __ ] even to this day
he's only a few years older than me and
that [ __ ] looks like damn arnold
schwarzenegger he worried it out like
[ __ ]
and he's a um a little bird pilot
for uh a uh a potent tate
a middle eastern potentate
in um
what's in abu dhabi
uh several of my aunts and uncles live
in abu dhabi
my family's been kind of tied in with
the middle east for quite a while going
all the way back
to iran during the shah area era of
[ __ ] iran
it's a long story
but my family's been filled with
military
and state department
d a
sf
delta up
so i was part of the community if you
understand
and uh
after i got out for medical reasons i
[ __ ]
did some time as a civilian and then
[ __ ] adventurers took me into [ __ ]
contracting later on
okay
um i'm [ __ ] retired now
physically mentally i'm still active i
can barely [ __ ] sleep at night but
no man you were in good units [ __ ]
good you the aviation units of the 101st
were [ __ ] great
uh 160th was [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
i had i had and turned down an offer
to be a [ __ ] mini gunner on a [ __ ]
on that special operation ch47 chinook
um
blanco says i can get you right in
you're the kind of guy we're looking for
uh you want to be a mini gunner on a
[ __ ] chinook [ __ ] then
uh during that time i was deep in the
[ __ ]
1327 recon platoon and i was like well i
don't know you know [ __ ] ranger
school and [ __ ] like that so
that's all i say about it wait
uconn cornelius also says gotta go glad
i finally got to say hello welcome
love the show listen on my commute to
and from work every day yeah thanks guys
that's awesome
i just like i like your name yukon
cornelius because that's a good name
well you know it's from the uh rank and
bass rudolph the redness reindeer like
christmas special
and i always used to really like yukon
cornelius because he would always like
he would do like the little
thing with his pickaxe and then he would
lick it
like he could find gold by like licking
it and that's i don't know why that like
that baby like laugh or a really lot
like when i was kidding i still remember
it
uh strawberry straw dogs 78 says
blueberry and strawberry pop-tarts are
life-sustaining i don't like the
blueberry ones but the strawberry ones
are delicious
thank you slime
that is very nice it's a very generous
thank you very much
that is very nice
uh zach says i agree with you on the
captain crunch best cereal ever yeah i
mean captain crunch
well crunch berry too i don't really
well
i could take or leave the crunch berries
but i really like the original
uh
they were all good it's all good they
were all good i haven't like i said we
don't really buy a lot of these they had
the peanut butter crunch too okay that's
good
i mean anything peanut butter all the
caffeine
i'm gonna eat that all of the captain
crunch
brand of cereals were [ __ ] good even
though it's all you know what i mean but
that line they were all good
i'm not really into like the fruity
stuff though i like that i like the
flavor although like i said i don't like
fruity pebbles i don't like fruit loops
i don't like tricks i don't like any of
that kind of stuff i liked it i liked it
all like my brother was into it and he'd
even drink the milk which like really
gross i liked the monster cereals with
[ __ ] blueberry and couchsurfing i
like scout chocolate yeah i liked all
that [ __ ] too i like scout shops i liked
the boxes obviously because there were
monsters
but i don't really like the cereal so
much which was a shame you want some
more ice in that
sure
victor says cocoa pebbles with banana
slices it's my go-to
oh man
there so much wrong with that sense
at least from my point of view like look
i like okay
i don't know why this is i like coco
crispies
but
whenever we had coco crispies like rice
krispies were okay too but it was always
just kind of like i would eat it
grudgingly
cocoa crispies i was into that but man
it had to like had a tiny amount of milk
in it because you put too much milk and
then it gets soggy
and then like i said my brother who's
four years younger than me i have two
brothers actually but i have one that
was four years younger
and he would have he got real into like
eating the cereal and he would like put
a [ __ ] ton of milk in it and then he
would just wait for it to get soggy and
then he would eat it and he would drink
the milk and that grossed me out like so
much i was just so gross out i like my
cereal to be crunchy thank you very much
um i'm not [ __ ] on you if you don't
like that but it's like i really really
like crunchy cereal so i like milk on
there but i like a little bit so i did
like cocoa crispies
but it had to have like literally like a
[ __ ]
just enough milk to like kind of damp
make it damp and then i would just like
kind of eat it like because it was still
crunchy if it was getting soggy i just
threw it out i don't want to drink the
milk that's disgusting but like i said
you know i'm not [ __ ] if you want to
do that but i don't like that so
so yeah and also
i don't know why i'm just i'm not i i
like fruit in general but i do not like
bananas i do not like bananas thank you
jeffy art thank you
thank you
i like your little i always like your
little cartoons they're so cute but yeah
so it's i don't know i don't like
bananas i mean
if it comes down to it i i especially
don't like i mean i don't like
natural bananas
but i especially don't like banana
flavored things you know what i mean
because i'm not a big fan of like actual
bananas
i'll eat them if i have to
but i'm you know i'm not gonna be happy
about it
but fake banana flavor like anything's
banana flavored yeah no thanks that's
like super super gross to me i don't
know why like i said i know some people
like that i don't like tom will eat it
but
danny rowling said trick cereal was good
before they switched to the [ __ ]
ball shape
i never liked tricks like i said we've
talked about this before and tom is
always trying to tell me
that because he's more into fruit
flavored stuff like fruit flavored ice
cream and flu fruit flavored
candy and all that kind of stuff that
that's somehow more manly than like
other soup which i don't get but
whatever
but i don't
i like fruit it's fine
i like some fruit flavored candy like
starburst delicious although i don't
like all the flavors i do like i like
the lemon i like the cherry i like the
strawberry and the orange those are good
lime and [ __ ] like that that can [ __ ]
off i don't like that but i don't know
thank you jeffrey thank you very much
i don't really like
um
like gummy kind of candies like i said
they're not terrible if that's all i had
to eat then i would eat them
but
yeah man it's like if if i'm gonna waste
the calories if i'm gonna eat
that many calories in candy i would
rather have something like delicious
like something good and that's just her
though
well that's what we were talking about
before you got here you missed like the
whole first part of the conversation
like i said you love all that [ __ ] and
you even like like fruity
ice cream and stuff like that which i'm
like i said i don't hate it like i said
if that was the only ice cream that was
available and i was like really want to
guys i was like yeah fine i'll eat that
but it's not my favorite it's not ever
what i would pick i saw a study that
said that women
more
more [ __ ] favored
chocolaty and caramelly type stuff on
average and then on average guys kind of
like fruitier stuff just the way it is
it's just now the thing about it danny
rowling brings up uh something that i
wanted to address because
that fruit kind of thing that i have
does not extend to either
watermelon or black cherry which are
delicious honestly anything watermelon
flavored or black cherry flavored yeah
i'll eat that yeah i'll eat that i don't
really like
i don't know but i don't like other
fruit flavors other than that okay we
got a decent crowd going on in in the
live chat if you guys want to want us to
change gears and go into any other kind
of situations go ahead and drop
something in the comments section i
don't know they seem to be happy
yeah y'all just wanna all fat [ __ ] want
to talk about food zach says banana
flavored runts were the best ones though
i find that hard to believe sir she
knows she hates artificial banana
flavors she doesn't like real i don't
even really like real babies i love
banana flavor yeah
although somebody's banana banana
chocolate bomb pops they used to have
yeah at the damn [ __ ] ice cream truck
i [ __ ] love those too like ollie like
look i'll eat a banana split yeah okay
um it's not my first choice
but if somebody said hey you want a free
banana split with like with all this ice
cream on it and stuff like that yeah
i'll eat that
but
fake banana flavor yeah no thanks the
thing about it is that it's hard to get
fruit flavor right if you're gonna do a
fake fruit flavor
i like
a cherry fake fruit flavor strawberry
fake fruit flavor and orange and lemon
are good to you
so i'll eat that so it's not so much an
aversion to
fruit it's just kind of like if i'm
gonna have
a dessert type of thing
like other day like when we went to rift
tracks
and we got we were like well we're going
to the movies which we don't do anymore
that jason and
his [ __ ] drinking michelob light
anything how's that tasted yeah and make
a little like okay maybe we should do a
whole taste test
i don't think i've ever had mklobe in my
entire life
i maybe have but i don't remember it
but the thing about it is that
so
so we stocked up
like at the store like did we went to
dollar
dollar general
and he gets all the fruity candy yeah
all the gummy stuff and stuff like that
i'm like man gross it's like that's a
lot of calories and i'm like look if i'm
gonna have that many calories i want
something like really really good i want
some like rich
chocolate and nuts and stuff like that
or toffee or something
so he bought like three or four bags of
fruit gummies
i bought one bag
of chocolate covered peanuts
and i enjoyed mine i a lot more i think
well no i i [ __ ] had several days of
eating [ __ ] yeah but see i can't do
that because it's like i can't eat
chocolate covered peanuts every day much
as i might like to because i'd be like
super fat but see the thing about it
though is that fruit gummies you would
think oh it's that's the healthier candy
but those have like just as many
calories they're just as fattening i'll
burn them [ __ ] up
come on so many steroids i'll burn that
[ __ ] up doesn't matter to me
camp guy said i love watermelon and
bubble gum please yeah yeah yeah some
bubble gum flavors and honestly when i
was a kid i used to i used to kind of
like bubble gum flavored ice cream like
the basket robins had that i love all
that exploitive
exploitative [ __ ]
ghetto flavors with the watermelon and
the cherry and the [ __ ]
pixie stix and all that [ __ ] that i grew
up with i like all that [ __ ] cheap
[ __ ] i [ __ ] love it i don't know what
it is like i said some like i'll eat
those but it's not my favorite yeah like
if somebody said
here's a dollar
go buy like
some good candy that you'd actually
enjoy
it wouldn't be fruit candy i can buy
either one of those i mean i mean i can
buy chocolatey [ __ ] too but i'll [ __ ]
get cheap [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] it's
all good to me i like it all it's just
it's a different experience
it is yeah
well on the thing about it too i kind of
feel like gummy candies maybe it's just
the gummy candies that i don't know if
this is just
i don't know if you like a while back
there was a thing i'll go buy a [ __ ]
chicko stick remember those [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh man chico state do you remember
back in the day and i told you about
this um i don't know if it's still up or
not yeah but there were sugar-free
gummy bears
and i'm pretty sure it was a haribo or
some like big brand or something yeah
the sugar-free gummy bears horrible
which uh like i said if you don't know
the stuff they use for like the
sugar-free
sodas and candy and stuff like that
um sometimes
that stuff will uh let's not let's be in
delicate about this we'll give you the
[ __ ] because that's kind of like the
same stuff that they put in laxatives
so
there was a
there was a post a camera was like a
five pound bag of
sugar-free gummy bears might have been
like an off-brand or might have been
like you know the big brand or whatever
and the
uh the reviews on that on amazon were
hilarious because
i guess like a lot of people like got
this five pound bag and like ate a bunch
of them like while they were sitting
there gaming or watching a movie or
whatever and then um
had some uh let's call them digestive
issues yeah zack anderson saying i love
big cheap big league chew i love this
did they still make that yeah i love
that [ __ ] too you eat that did they
still make that yeah it was good it was
like grape flavor
and then um
uh
straw dog says drinking an angry orchard
and guinness concoction first of all
yeah i love that that's good i like
angry artists that's called black velvet
is what that's called it's a variation
yeah where you take some kind of a cider
and a guinness stout and mix them about
50 50. yeah apple or pear or something
well again well angry orchard doesn't
have a uh no i'm just saying that if you
don't have angry orchards repair works
too any kind of cider and any kind of
[ __ ]
guinness stout
mixed about 50 50.
it's called black velvet
uh if it's not guinness stout like some
kind of a red beer or a darker beer
uh with with with [ __ ]
cider we call we used to call that
[ __ ] snake bite
but out of the two i always liked
[ __ ] black velvet
which is [ __ ] guinness stout
and cider
50 50. ship is awesome i love it
but it'll put a lot of weight on you
that's the problem
fattening
victor says kit kat is the best candy
i'm not going to argue with you i mean
kit kats are they're good but really
really good the best the best i mean
well okay now reese's peanut butter cup
but i i like stickers yeah
i like snickers but i like snickers if
they're frozen and i usually like the
fun size ones and i kind of i will argue
that a lot of candy bars are better in
their fun size
iteration because i i kind of feel like
the uh
i don't know the proportion is better a
couple days back
i got a [ __ ] i got a [ __ ] rhesus i
think it's called a
giant
which is it's a reese's peanut butter
cup that's [ __ ] yeah i've seen them
two and a half times and thickness i
think it was great it wasn't as good as
this looking reese's peanut butter cups
they're peanut butter cups they weren't
reese's i bought them at the damn candy
maker down
in in [ __ ] cambridge massachusetts
over [ __ ]
cambridge square
those things were the size of a goddamn
apple
i mean they were [ __ ] that thick
but each
each [ __ ] buttercup was five bucks
back in the 90s
but you can't eat all that at one time
though oh i did
they did
they were the size they were the size
of a [ __ ] cupcake
yeah yeah i couldn't eat that at once oh
man much as i would like to it was like
a whole meal i'd eat that [ __ ] and i was
like well i'm not eating the rest of
this yeah
the rest of today yeah i'll eat tomorrow
or the day after
well see that's another thing i would
argue
that as good as the classic reese's
peanut butter cup size is
i would argue that the fun size ones are
actually better because i think that the
proportion of chocolate to peanut butter
is better
in the single like the little single
ones i think honestly i think like all
the little bitty fun size bars like you
get at halloween and stuff i think those
are generally better i don't know i just
think the proportion of ingredients is
more satisfying yeah slide those clark
bars were good
yeah those are pretty good so we're zero
bars now see they still have zero bars
yeah they have car i haven't seen a
clark in a long time zero bars because i
got that white nougat with the [ __ ]
chocolate i thought it was marshmallow
is it marshmallow or no no it was like a
nougaty it was kind of stretchy they
were they were good real good
clark i haven't seen them in a long time
you could order them you could use the
order all that [ __ ] well that's the
thing there's a lot of online candy
stores that will sell you
because well
we even saw i even saw a documentary
about this where even like a lot of
classic candy that a lot of the original
companies don't make anymore but they
sold like all the recipes and the
licensing and everything like that to
like another company
that now makes them and like sell them
online like so they have amazon stores
you can get necco wafers you which which
i don't know why you'd want to you but
man when i was a kid we used to buy a
necklace because they were like a dime
you got a whole roll of neccos
neko wafer
was the original american candy i didn't
realize that those were from the 1800s
yeah they've been our own that's how old
those are they've been around a long
time and when you look at it in the
point of view that this is an 1800s
candy
well yeah they probably thought that
[ __ ] was delicious back then yeah
nowadays there's no reason to be eating
that kind of that damn waxy powder
but
they were kind of addictive you once you
ate one of them you wanted to eat more
of them it's like eating dust
flavored dust delicious dust yeah it's
weird
that sounds delicious it was just a
weird experience
[Laughter]
danny eating medicine
yeah and the only one that had a
distinctive flavor was the one that
tasted like black licorice
the rest of them didn't seem to really
have much of a flavor to them but we
loved them they were so cheap and you
could eat a [ __ ] ton of them
well i mean when you were a kid you were
just like you just learned to love
whatever you could afford yes
that's kind of that's what you had to
like put up with danny rowling said
hostess chocolate pudding pies honestly
yeah they're good i loved those yeah
that had snoopy on it right i kind of
feel like it had something i liked the
lemon ones better lemon ones were good
too i'm not gonna lie cherry ones were
also good they had a cherry one but i
for some reason the chocolate pudding
ones were my favorite and you could buy
them for nothing
yeah they were super cheap i used to
walk because my grandmother she had a
7-eleven like behind her house so you
could just like walk over there and like
buy snacks so like sometimes we go over
there for you non-americans up in europe
and other [ __ ] places in the world it
might even be the african continent
we had these [ __ ] pot we things that
we call pies
they weren't pies
it was a little package about this big
and you had a fold over
a [ __ ] like it was like a pie crust
and it was glazed in sugar
and there was a filling in the middle of
them and it was just kind of like
generic pie filling
some of it was chocolate
lemon
cherry
those are the main ones i remember i
remember
yeah i mean i'm sure there was other
ones but
and they had um they had peanuts
characters on them yeah charlie brown
and lucy and snoopy and stuff like dolly
madison made this
yes the south had different ones well
because dolly madison like um they i
don't know what larger company they uh
were a part of but they used to host all
of those they were they would sponsor
like all those peanuts
like christmas specials and stuff they
came like in in wax paper a wax paper
thing and it was kind of colored yeah
and you you could rip the end of it off
and it would come out look like a taco i
mean it was big it was pretty big for
for what you paid sure
and um
you didn't heat it up or anything you
just ate you just ate it kind of like
kind of like the pie
at mcdonald's like the hot apple pie but
it wasn't hot it was just
room temperature just room temperature
but they were
they were less than a dollar in those
days
i don't remember how much they were i
used to get i used to get the chocolate
ones
yeah it was something like that yeah 75
some
maybe less depending on when i was a
little kid they were probably 50
and then when i got older in my teenage
years they were probably 75
and you had this weird experience like
you actually ate a meal but you didn't
if you had probably enough calories yeah
if you looked at the nutrition there
wasn't much there but
they were only a little bit more than a
candy bar but a lot more filling than a
candy bar man i would go over to like
i'd be at my grandma's house like over
the summer because we usually stay there
in the summertime like while my parents
were working and we would walk over to
the 7-eleven
and i would get
a chocolate pudding
pie with snoopy on it yeah and then i
would get what the [ __ ] did they call
those things they used to sell them in
the front of the 7-eleven
that were
it was almost like a little comic book
but you folded it out and it was like a
like a scene like batman or ghostbusters
or whatever the hell was popular at the
time and then you could like like uh rub
off like the characters on there like
they had like a whole i don't know what
the [ __ ] was that called it was what was
the food
i just said chocolate chocolate pie okay
no it didn't come with food okay i said
i would go over there and get a pie okay
and then i would get that little thing
where you would like i don't remember
that yeah it was kind of like it was a
scene like usually it would be like a
batman said like you fold it out yeah
right and it was like a it was usually
batman or ghostbusters those are the two
where i remember and then it would come
with a sheet
of all these little characters like
doing [ __ ] like batman going like that
or whatever the [ __ ] and then like you
would put
the characters on the scene like
wherever you want it and then you'd rub
it off like with a pencil yeah and it
would come off like on the other side so
i would always get one of those and i
would get like a like a pie if you asked
me during that era and this is a long
time ago the lemon ones were the best
ones those were good too yeah those were
good too i mean lemon anything i only
eat lemon anything the lemon ones i
really like lemonade you could actually
heat them up a little bit in a microwave
yeah uh just for a few seconds just to
make a little softer
and the steam inside the wrapper would
make them a little like like it was
something that came out of the oven and
they were a little bit better
the uh i didn't like the chocolate ones
that much it was just i like the
chocolate pudding
it was chocolate i thought it was yes it
was chocolate pudding i didn't like that
as much it needed something like caramel
and nuts in it it's a really well it
needed a texture but yeah yeah but they
were so cheap they didn't put that in
there they're like no we're not going to
do it no it was basically like chocolate
pudding in a pie filled in a pie shell
is essentially what it was
um
oh somebody said uh sly said i still buy
zero bars white chocolate yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm not gonna like i love zero bars
i love white chocolate
uh and somebody said almond joy rocks
yes i also love all my joys i was going
through the damn check out of publix and
saw zero bar and like reached out almost
bought it you should have bought me one
yeah i almost bought it but they wanted
a lot for it man prices are going up i'm
not used to these new prices
i was like going they wanted almost two
dollars for that i'm amazed that they
still have zero bars because i kind of
feel like
[ __ ] like that like they had zero and
uno
uno was real similar to zero but i don't
really remember the difference you guys
in the comment section go tell me
yeah zero balls i kind of feel like uno
boo bar they were real similar there's
not even nowadays yeah i think uno might
have had peanuts in or something in it
but other than that is about the same
even nowadays there's still not enough
yeah white chocolate yeah although i
will say i really do like the hershey's
like cookies and cream
um although i kind of wish they would
just do a straight white chocolate bar
but most candy bars nowadays do have a
white chocolate variant uh even though
sometimes like even kitkat has one which
i'm a big fan of but i kind of feel like
most more of them should do that but
it's better than it was back in the day
because i i liked white chocolate from
when i was a kid and back in the 70s and
early 80s it was kind of hard to get
like white chocolate [ __ ] like i said
you had zero bars and at easter you get
white chocolate bunnies but they were
kind of like the redheaded stepchild
that they put over here and i was like
what i like that though and it's just
you know what i mean but nowadays now
they make like reese's with white
chocolate and like they have a snickers
i think that's white chocolate they have
like white chocolate versions of
everything but they're not like widely
available but at least they kind of have
them yeah but i really like those i'm
talking about how long have you been
streaming
two hours and thirty years okay
uh they're talking about gugu clusters
yeah they're good
for those two they're good yeah we're
talking about almond joy yeah i really
like all that so mounds are good too
because i'm all about chocolate and
coconut but almond joy is better because
it has like [ __ ] nuts in it obviously
um
does anybody have any questions about
any true crime cases or
paranormal or
current events anything if not we're
gonna sustain we're gonna be talking
about candy everybody's talking about
dime store [ __ ] okay everybody's talking
about kitty well we're all getting drunk
and we're talking about stores victor
said do they still sell whatchamacallit
bars those were good things for a long
time um i haven't seen yeah do they
i haven't seen a reggie bar in forever
man i used to love reggie bar
that's old school slide knows what a
reggie bar is he was a [ __ ]
a los angeles dodger if i remember
correctly
[ __ ] and he was like some [ __ ] he
was kind of like the bay of ruth of my
era
and they had a
that he had a [ __ ] candy bar came
from i think it was
mars m m's it was from one of the major
manufacturers and it was kind of like a
damn turtle
if you know what a turtle is it was like
kind of like a hundred thousand dollar
bar or a hundred grand bar is what they
call today it was like caramel
with peanuts yeah covered in chocolate
and it was flat and it was
man that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good a reggie
bar i haven't seen a reggie forever
it's making me hungry
make me miss the old days
tammy said lindor lint truffles are the
best chocolate yeah honestly i really
like and every now like around christmas
time
i'll usually buy myself a little bag
of the lindor white truffles like with
the peppermint in there another good one
was white chocolate and peppermint
another one that [ __ ] i grew up with
[ __ ] this sly he grew up in that [ __ ]
too it's called toffee faye
they still saw that yeah they still make
it we bought it not too long ago they're
wait they have it [ __ ] uh at the cbs
there's these little semi-circular
things those are good half a sphere
[ __ ] caramel with nougat and a
[ __ ] nut with
brown chocolate dark chocolate on top of
them they were [ __ ] really good i
remember when they were new
and i was buying them things they came
in like a pack of five or six in a long
bar
they were really good
i think it was uh what kind of nut was
that in that a hazelnut
i think it was a hazelnut oh it might
have been it was like
i remember we bought some not too long
ago because they still have them
everywhere they have them at cvs that's
one that's stuck yeah that was one that
stuck and when that [ __ ] came out i was
like oh i love these my mom's a little
bit more these are good it was like a
little boy it's like a ten i was sitting
there eating my mustache what are those
this is just a tough thing
and i gave her one and she said oh those
are good [ __ ] yeah yeah hard to go
wrong with that hard to go wrong with
that seriously
jason x says baby ruth sucks uh i'm
gonna discriminate no no no
i like baby babe ruth is good honestly
i'm even gonna uh i'll even stand up for
payday bar yeah which you don't even
have any chocolate it's just basically
all peanuts yeah
and nougat yep i like paydays yep i'm
you know i'm a big fan of peanuts
i'm not hating lynn was a sly said that
he's still alive tom what he said
and i think he was the only baseball
player that had a candy named after him
yeah
he was a he was he was a
african-american guy who was a [ __ ]
really i think he was a lot an la dodger
and he uh
[ __ ]
he was a [ __ ] really good batter from
what i remember all right [ __ ] you
threw a ball at him he hit that [ __ ]
ball and uh he was causing the dodgers
to win
they made a candy bar after him
you could probably order it special
through like retro
candy services there's a lot of shops
like that that's that [ __ ] reggie
brought that reggie bar was great it was
it was a round like that
and it was like a truffle
uh it was it was caramel with some nuts
i don't remember what kind of nut it was
it was probably peanuts and dark
chocolate over the over it
and uh when i was a kid man we buy a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of those
and you like
[ __ ] with stretch they were [ __ ] good
man really good
look for y'all youngsters
i'm be i'm i'm a wax old man he's gonna
do some old man [ __ ] right now we'll do
some old man [ __ ] right now
and sly gonna back me up on this [ __ ]
his 61 year old ass
food in the 70s was better
i don't know if i'd get that no some of
that food in the 70s was [ __ ]
maybe
and the early 80s [ __ ] round table
pizza was the [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] late 70s early 80s those
can't some of those candy bars are
[ __ ] fantastic
and i think it's because it wasn't the
food service industry was not quite as
corporate mass production there was
still
a little bit of craftsmanship in certain
things that they made
although i must attest
when the mid-80s had come around it had
gotten kind of bad
but i remember late 70s being really
good and when it came to food
there were some pizza places that you'd
go to even they were even though they
were chains
pizza hut in the 70s was [ __ ] great
really good well back then
it was a sit-down restaurant yeah it was
a sit-down restaurant you're gonna play
missile commander in the seventies and
then had a jukebox and everything yeah
and that pizza was good all the way up
until the
mid-90s
up until the mid 90s the pizza was
really good
especially that thin crust pizza that
they had pan pieces was good too
but [ __ ] i remember like 93 94 having
[ __ ] great pizzas
the pizza hut
in i had a pad pizza that had the
barbecue pan pizza
it was around 93 that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
fantastic i'm still trying to replicate
some of that [ __ ] that we used to taste
back then the cheese was better you'd
bite it and it would stretch way out it
was a real buffalo mozzarella cheese
it was just better
um
but there wasn't a lot
of times change
you go on youtube and look at the damn
urban exploration a lot of those [ __ ]
restaurants are long gone now and
abandoned
the profits aren't there
you know not a profit to keep that kind
of [ __ ]
running under today's
competition
it's sad but true
people are more
entertained by
their cell phones and what they can
stream than going to restaurants it used
to be
going to a restaurant was like a form of
entertainment you didn't have anything
else to do so you went to a restaurant
it was before the information era
well the thing about it too the the flip
side of that which i mentioned earlier
is that nowadays people are a lot more
savvy about yeah
food and people have been exposed to a
lot more different kind of like you know
flavors and stuff like that so it's like
you can't really get away with
being just like a shitty like mid-tier
restaurant so much anymore like if it's
not good like people won't go there well
all of that was even in change back when
we were kids
you know what i mean they were fighting
it was there was like a war going on
between the restaurants
uh when i was a kid
the [ __ ] that wasn't that good was
failing and stuff that was good was
succeeding but
oh in the end the internet won not
restaurants
that's the way it seemed you know i kind
of laughed because today earlier today
our friend uh dimitri
he posted i think it was in a facebook
group that i'm part of that was like oh
if you were are from central florida
you'll remember this and that and he
posted a thing about wags restaurant i
don't know if they had these around the
country
but
we had one in
daytona it was in the volusia mall
and me and my grandma and my great aunt
like when i was
little i was probably like five or six
seven years old
and my grandma and my great-aunt like
when i was staying there they would take
me to the mall and they would go
shopping in learners and all that other
kind of stuff and pennies and
everything looking for clothes
and we would have lunch at wags
and i used to [ __ ] love that my
favorite thing about that restaurant
was that
the whole
and this is a long time ago i was a
little kid but i remember like the whole
back wall of the dining room yeah was
all
like refrigerated cases where like all
their desserts were yeah so like you
could go over there and look and be like
there'd be slices of pie and i was like
i was all about that yeah because you
know how i do
slides in there talking about how that
i'm right
back in the day we would get excited
about real [ __ ] now it was before
virtual reality and [ __ ] online stuff
it was just a different era
which kind of takes me back to some of
the music that i grew up with [ __ ]
billy idol with that album that he had
called cyberpunk and he was talking
about how the in
how the internet would would change
things and he was absolutely right he
saw that [ __ ] coming
it's funny because
billy idol's fans hated that album back
in those days but
you go back and listen to it now which i
did a [ __ ] couple couple weeks back i
was like man he for
he foresaw a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] about
how the internet would change the world
the older generations were more about
being there and it was more
more of a [ __ ] analog [ __ ]
experience and restaurants were part of
it restaurants are not as big today as
they used to be
[ __ ]
like for instance my parents generations
they thought restaurants were like
nightclubs you go to
you you gotta go
eat and eat a dinner
at some
basically a corporate restaurant and
they're judging the place
about what a time that they had there
and i was like this is a denny's what
are you [ __ ] worried about what
happened at danny's for but you know
what i mean it was just the thinking was
very different back then don't [ __ ] on
denny's they got good breakfast danny
says
the [ __ ] that little pan breakfast
that they had in the skillet [ __ ]
yeah hell yeah honestly [ __ ]
place where i used to work like several
years ago there was a denny's not too
far and like every now and then i would
call them and like order like a skillet
lunch or something like that and i would
go there and pick it up and that [ __ ]
was delicious i'm not sure not denny's
so you know what i mean
i just i don't know i just kind of feel
like people are more discerning nowadays
and i don't think that's a bad thing
but
i do
i don't know like i'm not
i'm not a real nostalgic person like i
get why people yeah there were some [ __ ]
that was better in the 80s but
if you came to me right now and said hey
you want to go back to the 80s i'm like
no thanks no thanks like because yeah
there was like some cool [ __ ] back then
if you weren't there but
i don't know i just i don't think i
would want to everything else was like
harder i kind of feel like everything
else is easier nowadays and i really
wouldn't want to go back to that but i
do i do get why some people like that
but like i said i never wanted to be one
of those people that was just kind of
like back in my day it was like so much
better blah blah blah i just like i
don't want to be that person and i've
never been that person so it's again
like every
time period has good [ __ ] and every time
period does bad annoying [ __ ] so
i always just try to
you know whatever time we're living in
like what's the best [ __ ] that's
happening nowadays it's like it's
probably better than what was going on
back then so
i don't know i'm not real nostalgic like
i said i do like 80s era [ __ ] i do like
that kind of stuff but
you know somebody asked me if i wanted
to actually go back there and live no no
absolutely not just too difficult
we have so much more stuff nowadays and
it's like in a lot of ways it's a lot
better
um so
but i get like why you would think
otherwise i get that
you know
and let's see how long we've been
streaming uh two hours and 46 minutes
okay 46 minutes
do you want to uh
you getting hungry yeah i got all yeah i
got all kinds of damn crab salad and
everything i make a crab salad sandwich
down there i might maybe two you want
two i can make it two of them starting
78 said i remember when pizza hut was
given those buttons and free pizza for
reading a certain number of books per
month yeah i remember that pizza hut had
their yeah book club and every summer
like you'd have you had to like if you
brought in things like you read a book
and you had it did you have to like do a
book report i don't really remember but
they had some way of like proving that
it's like you'd read all these books and
stuff like that and then you come and
get like free pizza i remember that i
remember that
uh the chop suey chinese restaurant we
went to as a kid is closing down with
almost 50 years of operating yeah i mean
sly says uh you're also right jenny me
and tom are old school today is about
making life conscientious yeah it's like
i'm old too like i'm honestly like only
i'm almost 50 like i'm almost a couple
years you know i'm just a couple years
younger than him
but
like i said i'm not really i've never
been the kind of person i'm just not the
kind of person to like romanticize the
past like some things are better about
the past i'm not saying
and i do yeah but i kind of feel like
i'm more objective about it
like i tend not to be real nostalgic
about it's like oh this was what it was
like when i grew up and it should always
be like that [ __ ] that i don't want i
don't want that to happen i don't want
that to happen because you'd never like
make any progress
some of those some of those [ __ ]
pizzas some of those pizza places were
[ __ ] fantastic well yeah i'm not
saying that like like i said like back
in the past yeah there was some better
[ __ ] about the past but honestly it's
like i don't get people that just
romanticize the past because it's like
you know yeah there was like some good
[ __ ] about the past and you probably
like remember that now that you're older
but it's like there was a lot of shitty
stuff about that too that you probably
don't remember shopping sucked you could
just couldn't get them that's what i'm
saying it's like i remember now it's
just like god everything's so easy it's
like everything i want you to fight
anything it's like oh i just want this
five minutes and then like
two or three days from now it'll show up
on my [ __ ] doorstep that's awesome
you can find anything anywhere that's
awesome that's not the way it was back
in the day and honestly like nowadays
like just the [ __ ] that we're doing
right now we're talking to you guys you
guys are all around the world we're
doing this that was a fantasy background
and it's like nobody was thinking about
that and it's like
this is television you could talk to
people through that didn't exist in the
[ __ ]
80s we're talking about
that's what i mean we were even thinking
about that yeah
and that would have been a fantasy
and i've told you before because i'm a
writer i'm also a graphic designer i
really like doing
whole like book projects right baby
parker just ordered pizza hut
i'm not [ __ ] on pizza pizza it's
good yeah it could be good i mean
honestly we usually get where we live
now like we usually get dominoes because
it's right there that's like the only
thing that's close enough to deliver but
and you know it's fine i don't usually
get pizza from there i usually get a
sandwich to be honest i usually get one
of those or i make i make pizza here
well yeah that's what i mean i'm just
saying if i order from there which i
don't usually but i usually get a
sandwich or like a salad or something
yeah but uh but yeah so
the fact that i can
write a book
i can lay it out exactly how i want it i
can design the cover i can do it and
then i can put it online
anybody in the world can buy that that's
amazing yeah i mean like
that was what i dreamed about in the 80s
and 90s i really wish that that could
have been i mean i don't think i dreamed
that
specifically
but had i known that that was gonna that
that was coming i'd have been like yeah
exactly that's what i want to do so i
would not like go back to that time no
way so i talked about how good the music
was in the 70s and 80s it was well
that's true yeah it was it was better
that's true yeah i mean that now i'm not
saying there's not good music around
nowadays just you don't hear because
there is behind it but you have to like
look you have to it's a lot more
proactive because there's so much
yeah you what it is is that the popular
corporate-backed music of our era
[ __ ] sucks
to find good music you gotta find
[ __ ] individual creators on [ __ ]
youtube sure you gotta go through that
you gotta find exactly what you're
looking for which in a way you kind of
had to do that back then but it was
easier you're right like back then like
even back yeah that's what i'm saying
like even back then like the corporate
backs like music that sucked back then
too
and you still had to like look a couple
layers down like to find the good [ __ ]
but it was easier back then like
nowadays there's good [ __ ] everywhere
but it's like there's so much good [ __ ]
it's like an embarrassment of riches
that you have to like
dig around sly there are late 70s early
80s revival bands of all the [ __ ] we
came up with and these are young people
and they are [ __ ] doing this [ __ ] on
youtube and blow your [ __ ] mind
they're good
they can fake the 80s like [ __ ] crazy
all right and you're like going yeah
that's right that's that's what we were
talking about
they're out there are they famous no
they're not famous just that a lot of
young people like like the very early
80s well i've said before like i think
like even something like let's talk like
stranger things which is like massively
you know hugely successful
that was made by two brothers who i'm
pretty sure were not even born right in
the [ __ ] 80s
but they
they saw this captured it they're like
okay yeah
because when i saw it i was like yep
that's what it was like yeah so the fact
that and i've seen like that's not just
them like i've seen some other like
movies and stuff like that that have
been made by uh people that weren't even
born back then but were just really into
it and they just made something that was
set in that time period i'm like holy
crap
that's what it was like
so
you know
yeah that's what i'm saying it's just
not that that's what i mean when i'm not
like a nostalgic person like i like a
lot of things from back then
but i have like a more objective view on
it it's like yeah it was a lot of cool
[ __ ] but there was a lot of really
annoying [ __ ] too yeah that wasn't about
70s 70s and 80s was bad that's what i'm
saying
but there was some good [ __ ] there and a
lot of the a lot of the young people
today are looking back to that era going
oh yes because 70s and 80s was
the [ __ ] that was really good was kind
of a do-it-yourself kind of motif anyway
i mean it was analog
we didn't really have
i mean even some of the great mega bands
like blondie if you actually analyze it
that's a do-it-yourself band
um there isn't a whole lot new there
it's just a new packaging it's doo-wop
music
doo-wop mixed with [ __ ] disco every
now and then but but they were good
they're real good and you know and it
just that goes across the board
how long you been talking
almost three hours it's almost time to
shut it down
yeah probably yeah i'll get i'll make it
something to eat yeah i'm starving okay
sly says i love stranger things i'm
still trying to get tom to sit through
it because i've been i haven't seen it
he hasn't seen it i've seen it i've seen
all of it
but
uh i keep telling him it was like you
would really like it but you have to
watch it from the beginning otherwise
it's not gonna yeah just like make sense
to you i'll watch it honestly too
i just found this out
doesn't it seem like we just watched
the fourth season of cobra kai
right seems like i love covering the
fifth season is coming out
this month i'm pretty sure we're gonna
see that [ __ ] because i was just
looking at i saw some article the other
day that was talking about oh the best
like horror and sci-fi that's coming to
like netflix and all like hulu and
everything and i was just like cobra kai
season five already yeah holy [ __ ] i
feel like just watch slide if you
haven't seen cobra kai man watch all
that [ __ ] you'll get it you'll
understand you're only a couple years
older than me man you'll understand
exactly what's going on that's a [ __ ]
karate kid
yeah
i don't know if you've seen karate kid
the three movies from everybody's seen
karate [ __ ] i got them
we grew up with them you know what i
mean everybody's seen so they did a
whole series called clicking cobra kai
and that went that was on youtube for a
while and now it's uh where'd they move
netflix netflix it's all on netflix
right all seasons right i think they did
buy the the previous seasons that have
been on youtube right yeah yeah and you
want to watch the whole [ __ ] thing
all kinds of [ __ ] well again just like
any series you kind of have to watch
over the whole thing to get like the
full impact which like i said that's why
if we're going to do stranger things you
got to start in the beginning cheesy ass
1980s style karate movies but leans into
it but it leans into the [ __ ] they know
it's the best possible yeah it's great
it's great the best possible like i said
they hit that really good balance
between
iron like being ironic and also being
earnest like i kind of feel like they
they hit that a good balance of those
things yeah okay
[ __ ] sly scene one two and three are
karate you gotta see [ __ ] cobra kai
man
it's so good yeah i didn't expect to
like it as much as i liked it
really really cobra kai now how many
seasons of cobra car are there well the
fifth one is coming out like this month
i guess i just found out there are four
seasons of cobra kai
on youtube excuse me uh
go watch them you'll you'll like them
and you'll [ __ ] fit right in you'll
know exactly what the [ __ ] going on i
mean it's fine and it's got the original
cast
from [ __ ] they got man they got
everybody back
everybody everybody everybody except
[ __ ] marita he's dead well he died
yeah mr miyagi is not in it they're
they're not gonna like bring him back
from the dead that would be [ __ ] up
right yeah but no it's [ __ ] it's a
great series
great series not a good series a great
series
i loved it
yeah it was that was like way like a
hundred percent better than it actually
had any race yeah it didn't have right
to be that good it really did but i was
just like i was really surprised like oh
my god this is actually quite awesome
right this is quite awesome
uh are you guys watching house of the
dragon we are not um i still haven't
seen man there's like so much stuff i'm
behind on seriously
and then when i found out that like new
season of cobra kai was like i was just
like oh yes
as if that wasn't enough i have like so
many i haven't even seen like a lot of
the big tv shows that everybody talked
about i haven't seen most of game of
thrones i haven't seen
man just so much stuff
so much stuff love you guys haha
no for the funny thing about cobra cut
is that that that's just real
okay they had people like that
they had people like that [ __ ] um
the black dragon society was kind of
like cobra kai
which that was the dude [ __ ] what was
his name
[ __ ] the hairdresser guy yeah in the
comic books
[ __ ] we did a show partially on that guy
and
now cobra kai actually there's a certain
amount of reality to it
back in the 70s and 60s you had [ __ ]
count dante count dante
pokey's back there count dante the
[ __ ] deadliest man alive with the
[ __ ] killer [ __ ] death touch hands
that you saw on the in the back of the
[ __ ] punisher comic books and in
[ __ ]
in the [ __ ] middle of the [ __ ]
spider-man and [ __ ] yeah
they had dudes that were like that
and he was from chicago he had his
own dojo
and uh he had his own students and they
went through what was called the [ __ ]
chicago dojo wars
where cal dante [ __ ] actually [ __ ]
got into some deadly battles with some
other dudes
and [ __ ] a couple of his dudes got
killed in those fights so it wasn't
it's [ __ ] crazy when you actually
look
they're fighting over karate and who has
the best karate
and i will read away i will reiterate at
this point i'm very surprised that most
dudes make it to adulthood yeah
yeah
the stupid [ __ ] they will count dante
seriously
zach says hey jenny if one of your
stories was turned into a movie who
would you want to direct it
um
ooh
i have one story in particular
uh that was inspired by david lynch so i
would actually really like to see if
david lynch would direct it
so there's that
but generally i don't know maybe um
maybe at least see like re aster or
something like that take a swing at one
of my things i don't know my my style
i'm not really sure it's kind of like
all over the place so i'm not really
sure like if there's any directors in
particular
that because they're all kind of like
different startup 78 said the young cast
of yellow jackets which is set in the
90s commented that the period 90s
fashion is pretty much what they wear
today yeah i kind of feel like
everybody's wearing 90 [ __ ] nowadays
there was count dante
from
all right that man actually existed and
there's a whole [ __ ] story behind
that
that was the original [ __ ] mma
[ __ ]
and um
when you look at [ __ ] cobra kai
and uh
hold on
you look at [ __ ] like cobra kai and i
was [ __ ] he was a hairdresser he said
how pretty he could cut hair
he was a creator and a destroyer
but
[ __ ] are crazy how did they
survive you're right jenny
how did how did how do men
live i don't understand how they are
still around like you'd think that
evolution would have killed them off
yeah oh [ __ ] i was gonna say and there
he is on the cover of black belt [ __ ]
magazine all right
let's roll that [ __ ]
yep
he was the original i mean he's trying
so hard he was there he was the original
[ __ ] steven seagal
but they said he was a maniac and that
he could fight
sure but that's the thing it's like i
don't know even if you can fight or if
you can't that's almost like uh a moot
point
because you're posing like that on the
cover and if you do that then i'm
automatically going to see that and be
like that dude is just like
he's fronting is what he's doing like he
can't like i could beat his ass probably
but i mean maybe he could be my ass i
don't know but it just seems like when
they're trying so hard like that
it makes me
really question their actual it was
another era i know but i'm just saying
i'm just saying
automatically if you're trying hard like
that i just kind of i feel like there's
probably like some your compensation it
was just another era i'm cure
compensating yeah
picture said emma robert emma roberts
could play me oh that's very flattering
thank you very much
uh louis says uh watch it jenny talking
about um
house of the dragon it's a standalone in
a way okay well i'll probably get around
to it i'll probably get around to it
sly says black belt magazine we would
spend our last dime to get those hell
yeah
and then we [ __ ] play the damn video
games like the karate video games and
[ __ ] at 7-eleven
black belt right next to us
not knowing what was [ __ ] and what
was true but we would believe idiot were
kind of [ __ ] back
back in the early 80s
it was just a funny time you know
i actually thought that a dude could
punch his hand through an iron grill
that was smaller than his [ __ ] wrist
you know what i mean and then pull it
back out just through chi power
did you not realize that like magic was
a thing like magic like magicians were
well
magazines so it must have been something
to it i thought it was paranormal
you know i thought i thought they could
do something paranormal but it's not
though uh they're just
not uh it's kind of like [ __ ] santa
claus isn't really either yeah it's just
like
what's more likely are they telling
everybody what are they lying well what
they're talking about was [ __ ] the
dude who could through the chee balls
what's his name [ __ ] oh yeah that
[ __ ] that guy
yeah you know she knows exactly who i
know i know you're talking about yeah i
think there's like yeah i'm throwing
chee ball right now
yeah i forgot his name
but that [ __ ] would just lie his
ass off that he could stillman
is that his name stillman
that doesn't sound right but maybe
tillman stillman
um
dilman
[Laughter]
he could [ __ ] he claimed that he
could just knock you down by doing that
and throwing out a che ball
i you know i mean he could only knock
over his students i would take great
delight yeah in standing across from him
and watching him do all his moves and me
just standing there completely
unaffected
that would be very very hilarious what's
funny about that [ __ ] is that he could
only knock over his students by doing
that sure not any skeptics
yeah because i'd just be standing there
going is this supposed to be doing
something or not tillman
greg tillman was that his name i
remember i don't remember but they said
that [ __ ] you know i mean they would
show him doing that and his students
would fall over like you know okay i
knocked down the analog for that yeah if
you guys remember back in the day you
would have those uh faith healers like
benny hinn yeah they'd be like i'm
you're healed and he would like put his
like [ __ ] the heel of his hand like
up to your forehead oh my god i'm healed
of my cancer my ass cancer or whatever
and they would like fall down and they'd
be like oh my god now i can walk and
before i was crippled it's the same kind
of thing yeah those are plants
yeah we all believe those magazines back
then yeah we did we did because we
didn't know any better
and then
if it was in a magazine it must have
been true you know it's written down and
somebody printed it they had dudes
showing up with night vision goggles and
all kinds of [ __ ] equipment saying
that they were doing [ __ ] uh that
they came from vietnam and we're doing
all this [ __ ]
special operation stuff for the cia and
[ __ ] killing people and [ __ ]
knocking them out was just with oh [ __ ]
see you did like that and even the
bracelet falling off
all that weird [ __ ] that's going on
that's nice it turns out that that's the
same dude [ __ ] from [ __ ] death
sport
bloodsport bloodsport yeah what was that
guys jean-claude van damme yeah well he
played frank ducks ducks frank ducks
frank ducks claimed to be delta force
and all kinds of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] well
sure might as well yeah there was
nothing to that dude
but they put that [ __ ] in black belt
magazine make up all kind of stuff and
when you're [ __ ] 15 16 17 18 19 back
in those arrows oh my god
oh [ __ ] might be something to that
badass if there wasn't something to it
it would never show up in that magazine
that was the thinking of the time
that was the thinking of the time they
put that [ __ ] in print it's got to be
true
well yeah we didn't realize that print
was basically like [ __ ] reddit
well everything is
but we you know we didn't know back then
you might as well just put that in the
comments section on youtube they didn't
give a [ __ ] no they didn't [ __ ] make
anything up but it was another era danny
rowling said didn't frank ducks exp
inspire the american ninja films as well
i think he would probably yeah i think
he might have been friend ducks was the
greatest liar of all times
he got away with it for a long time you
gotta give him that
i mean he was a good bullshitter he came
up with a gr with he came he invented
the american ninja phenomenon basically
and uh okay cool
i mean yeah good job hollywood made a
lot of money off frank dux's lies
well and probably a lot of independent
studios too and i can't be too bad at it
because it's like i'm sure a lot of like
hard-working
actors and editors and special effects
guys and [ __ ] like that stuntmen made a
lot of money off those cheap jack ninja
movies yeah
they at least got a job out of it so i'm
not going to be that and what was
awesome and what was really awesome
about the whole thing is that steven
seagal jumps in on the tail end of that
basically steven seagal is [ __ ]
building his [ __ ]
building his reputation well he saw
franklin from ducks or frank dukes
douche frank
frank dude frank do she sees frank
douche and he's like oh yeah hell yeah i
could do that yeah i could do that too
except even more obnoxious yeah yeah
yeah sure and and then there comes
[ __ ] there comes [ __ ] hard to kill
great movie love hard to kill and then
[ __ ]
um
the one uh [ __ ] the one reason on the
ship was the [ __ ] one where he's on
the ship
there's i got two of them out for under
siege i understand
under siege one i'm just trying to think
of it's like out under below down down
down kill death left right
blade
you could use a computer to generate
those names i'm sure there's probably
look if there's a giallo movie name
generator there's a steven seagal movie
named generator somewhere out there i'm
sure somebody google that right now and
tell me if there is one there's got it
and i'll rail on cigar i [ __ ] rail on
cigar being a fan of seagull at the same
time [ __ ] uh bar for death out for
justice
[ __ ] above the law
under the law
to the side of the
inside
you can do whatever you [ __ ] want
with that [ __ ] sitting on top
blowing the law sucking the hood of the
law
[ __ ] playing with the nuts
just whatever whatever you know [ __ ]
but oh my god we should do a whole show
about like coming up with [ __ ]
stevenson yeah but uh
out of them all out of them all are
[ __ ] under siege
under siege i mean i kind of feel like i
love the only
that yeah
yeah under siege of [ __ ] and i use
the term good advisedly it's just kind
of like that's it undersea out of like
just
relatively comparatively like all of the
output yeah that one is actually like a
real movie yeah
that you could maybe like enjoy yeah
under siege two was fun too
i don't watch that one again i don't
remember ever seeing that that was the
one that was happening on the train
and it was happening on the train and
he's there with his niece
and he's making a movie he's on his
knees i was going to say was he banging
the knees he was she was telling his
niece how pretty she was
you know
well you know so he's the creepy uncle
oh yeah oh yeah definitely definitely
gross you got to see it though but they
played it off like why did that not
surprise me yeah that seems that's
totally
that's completely our brand
it's steven skull he's gonna be a creep
the [ __ ] under siege was he gonna was
he gonna like try and uh diagnose her
with breast cancer you're making me
wanna watch these movies
knows man he's the proper he's of the
proper
he's the proper age to understand the
mentality of the era
it was not meant to be taken seriously
it was all entertainment okay
and it was fantasy and you were supposed
to kind of escape off into this [ __ ]
and pretend that something like this
could actually happen
and that you are starring in this movie
that's part of it too
it's a self-insertion i'll tell you yeah
because you secretly going like yeah i
could do that
this movie's about me i mean this
movie's actually about me meanwhile
every normal person that's watching with
you it's like shut up what you've been
talking you can't do that but they knew
what they were doing back then they knew
how to [ __ ] write i said it's a
fantasy insert they knew how to write
back then
to [ __ ] pull random [ __ ]
into this [ __ ] male fantasy yeah they
knew how to do it
it was good it was good they were fun
when you're young you buy it when you
get a little bit older you go oh i see
what you did that's what you did yeah
that's why i like that movie okay i got
you [ __ ] but when you were in your
20s
probably that would they had your number
yeah they knew how they knew how to
[ __ ] pull you into it sure you're
like you could be as great as this dude
you could be a great assistant you
secretly are as great as i could also be
watching i just don't know ladies
jumping out of cakes and like being
[ __ ] exactly a navy seal
secret we are a navy seal with a pretend
cajun accent yeah
yeah at any moment
hot ass playboy bunny gonna jump out of
a [ __ ] cage with her [ __ ] kids
you're gonna save this [ __ ] because the
[ __ ] the admiralty is going to talk
to you over the damn cell phone and
you're going to figure it out and you're
going to [ __ ] save the [ __ ] from
tommy
hope tommy
there's no match for you and [ __ ] oh
what's his name oh crazy [ __ ]
what's that most crazy about the bucy
boosie yeah yeah
that was the shaker you see was it not
oh no that was that was the senior bc
okay back when abusie was a boosie okay
jake bc was in the brighteners yeah big
boosters they're both they're both
they're both good
but gary's even he's more boosting than
jake than jake
he's the busiest that [ __ ]
okay that's the wino boosie okay and
he's out there doggy yeah you know how i
take you know what am i talking about i
don't need any mental evaluation yeah
look at that that's what he's doing says
every person that absolutely does need
him
[Laughter]
[ __ ] boost he was the [ __ ] though
don't make me wanna you're making me
want to watch these old boys well now
see straw stronger 78 brings up a good
thing yeah executive decision and that's
steven seagal is in the and i haven't
seen the crustal is in that oh [ __ ] so i
kind of feel like that's probably one we
should do i've seen it but it was like a
long time ago
if you send it to me i'll [ __ ]
overview it i'd love to see it but i
don't i don't have that one
kanavatsan says segal needed a movie
with a sheet of kim kicking count dantes
yeah yeah honestly i would probably pay
a few bucks to like watch that because
that would probably be hysterical sheet
of kim would never show up on set though
he'd be sneaking around the outside of
your uh of your
suburban rambler
is shaking under the windows and like
picking up look i'm a ninja
a sheet of kim was [ __ ] deep
deep in the larping community he was
afraid that's a nice way of putting it
he was afraid to be around real march
martial artists like steve seagal so he
was so he was that's like that's pretty
bad yeah it's pretty bad if you're
afraid that you're gonna get your ass
kicked by steven secault like i said he
to be fair he could sit on you okay
which you know that would probably like
uh that would be bad okay
if y'all don't know who a sheet of kim
is a shitty kim is a [ __ ]
a fake ninja all right
and he's got to be at 80 now all right
uh you can go on you on facebook and go
look up black dragon fighting society
and there's a bunch of videos on there
made by a guy that called the pink man
and he'll tell you all about a sheet of
cam in his history uh ishida kim is a
fake ninja a white dude
who claims to be trained by japanese
ninjas even though kim is a korean
[ __ ] i mean he looks like some
[ __ ] that would have worked in
like a stereo store back in 1978 she the
kim probably weighs 125 pounds like did
you see boogie nights right and you saw
like the white guy that worked in the
stereo store back then that's that guy
the kim weighs a probably about 125
pounds he's probably about five seven
all right
um he put out a bunch of videos that he
sold the kids of him showing
jitsu tactics of how to [ __ ] duck
down underneath windows as you pass
which i honestly i would never you never
i'm really really glad that i paid 19.99
plus shipping and handling right how do
you jump up and throw sand how to
duck underneath the window to prevent
being seen i mean that is some like that
is some good information is she the
kim's main skill was to throw sand in a
motherfucker's face
he got that from like those old comic
book things with like the the 98 pound
weekly right
sand it like so but you got it i mean it
works to be fair
25 skinny 125 pound skinny white boy in
his 40s with a [ __ ] beard with a
[ __ ] pocket full of [ __ ] sand
okay he's always walking around with
sand in his pockets to throw that [ __ ]
on you let me tell you something [ __ ]
mr kim you're gonna get your ass whipped
okay
all right the sand is not enough
i mean it would probably if you're going
to go that route
a sheet of kim just
just i'm just blue skying here yeah if
you're going to go that route probably
it would be better
rather than having sand in your pocket
maybe have a little vial of maybe i
don't know sulfuric acid yeah that would
probably work a little bit better
talk about how [ __ ] hilarious those
videos are yeah they're on facebook
they're super funny i found them on
facebook
just go on facebook and look up black
dragon fighting society and those videos
are all there because they're awful
they're off on youtube they got taken
down
black dragon fighting facade black
dragon fighting society on youtube and
[ __ ] look at pink man's videos he's
got a bunch of them and he's got
something about ninjas he's got him
about [ __ ] uh frank ducks he's got
him about
[ __ ] a shitty cam and uh
he's a great
producer even though he's a troll and he
says crazy [ __ ] but he made some really
good videos and he's got this nerdy
voice it sounds like woody allen
telling you about [ __ ]
martial arts but he uh great videos
great look at the rest of him starling
says there should be a game get random
steven seagal and liam neeson movie
titles and determine which one stars in
which movie see i don't
i kind of feel like the whole thing
about and maybe this is kind of the same
way that they make uh a haunting
uh episode titles is the kind of the
same way that they come up with steven
seagal
movie titles i think you have you know
how you have those like uh what is it
called like magnetic poetry or whatever
you get like the little box and it's
like a bunch of little magnets that have
like one word on there and like you kind
of like and rearrange them however you
want i kind of feel like that's how they
come up with steven seagal they're
always kind of like two or three words
very pithy
and they're always kind of like you know
it's like an action word and it's like
we're we're out for death or we're
above the law or this that and the other
like very very short very punchy like i
get it but
like i said it's kind of the same thing
that happens with the haunting episodes
where it's like everything is like
echoes from the grave or
you know uh [ __ ] from the past or
whatever it's just like they always have
these kind of like and i can't remember
like one for the other because
they're all like too similar they're
like not really distinctive i get that
maybe at the time which is probably all
they're worrying about they're just like
yeah that sounds like something we want
to see let's go see
above the law or next to the law or
whatever the [ __ ] the movie is called
next to the law
i'd probably go see if it would be
called next little not gonna lie
standing next to the law
in the elevator
um i don't know i'm just making stuff up
danny rowling said i heard steven seagal
was asked to perform his smash hit
punani song super bowl half time yeah
yeah yeah
i you know what i might actually pay to
go see the super bowl well i had to
actually watch the super bowl if like he
actually did that what is that it's just
it's not tequila is it no okay no same
as what you're drinking it's just it's
just got a little bit of uh okay let's
call it
okay look
before we end the show i'm gonna [ __ ]
defend the honor of martial arts okay
are you really yes
okay um
where all that crazy [ __ ] came from was
bruce lee
bruce lee back in the 60s and 70s uh was
saying that there had to be a martial
art where you would be more free more
free
form where there wasn't a lot of rules
so you could see what style would
actually win
that never happens during bruce lee's
lifetime later on shortly yeah he died
later on unfortunately
later on in the 90s something called
ultimate fighting appeared which [ __ ]
sly remembers what i'm talking about
and ultimate fighting was closer to what
bruce was talking about
but probably the ultimate version of
what bruce lee was talking about was mma
okay
mma is actually something that actually
works all right it's actually how to
beat a motherfucker's ass
which involves punching kicking
grappling and [ __ ] ground game well
just doing whatever doing whatever it
takes it's all contextual right
but back in the 80s [ __ ] frank dooks
and [ __ ] [ __ ] is listening to what
um
listening to what [ __ ] bruce lee's
thinking he's thinking of the [ __ ]
movie bloods
bloodsport
where it's a [ __ ] martial arts fight
to the death
the kumite yeah the kumite
no that's not what that's not what it
would be in real life what it would
really be in real life would be mma
and dudes like frank ducks would not
have made it in mma
um
bruce lee would have made it in mma but
he would have had to have trained for
mma he'd have to pick up a couple more
pounds and learn a ground game bruce was
good even though he was an actor i mean
he was in good shape he was in good
shape he was good
he was an actor he came from chinese
theater which is mostly dance and fake
martial well jackie chan did too and i
and jackie chan could probably kick my
ass even nowadays right but those dudes
had to work okay they had to work and
they had to work by they're in good
shape so they weren't out there in these
fights so they're beating beating each
other up and then they're out for
[ __ ] three or four months to heal up
they didn't have time for that
but what
when you go back and listen to what
bruce bruce lee's interviews and what
he's talking about with martial arts and
what has to happen he's describing mma
so he was right that did happen
and um to his credit bruce would have
been good at mma
he would have to pick up some pounds
uh
so he could wrestle and pick up a ground
game so he could wrestle but no bruce
would have been good he was good
even though he was not a pro fighter he
was an actor
but everybody who's dealt with him
and knew him
said he was good
he wasn't the kind of guy he wanted to
[ __ ] with even though he didn't wave at
like 135 pounds
but he was in good shape
he was fast
real fast
he just couldn't grapple
well he could grapple but he wasn't
trained to grapple
and and wrestle
and that's what he lacked
but they couldn't imagine he couldn't
imagine what
free-form fighting in its ultimate
form would have been
most people thought it was more along
the lines of what count dante thought
which is stylized kicking and spinning
and [ __ ]
jumping up and spinning around and
kicking a [ __ ] in the head which
that works but it's just
it doesn't work against a real trained
fighter
they were you know we're that works
against just random dudes
khan's asking about chuck norris
chuck was good too he was he was good um
in his day although i will say i think
bruce lee was a much better actor than
john chuck norris not really that great
an actor these guys were dudes of their
era
um
if chuck was a young guy wanting to do
what he does now and say well i'm gonna
make a name for my he'd be an mma he
wouldn't have been in
karate or kung fu type [ __ ]
you can use some of that like the
gracies do that like that brazilian jiu
jitsu
this did pretty good in mma great you
know i wouldn't [ __ ] with the gracies
uh because it's like
like an oriental martial arts
but it also has [ __ ]
grappling and
wrestling in it
most fights end up on the ground most
real fights do okay so you got to have
that that's what that is that's what
that's all about
sly says sunny chiba r.i.p was a
grappler yeah
like sonny chibo was actually like i saw
a bunch of yeah i remember him
kanavatsan said in a real fight he would
have won chucker bruce probably chuck i
would have chug mass
and i'm not a big fan of chuck norris
like i said i had to
i probably brought this up before but my
ex-husband was like a big fan of like
chuck norris so i saw all of that
[ __ ] movies even all the bad
ones
so quantity has a quality all its own
not a great actor gonna say mass helps
okay
um i mean you look at me look you guys
look at me i [ __ ] look like i'm
[ __ ] rich
but i'm only five six
size
means a lot in a fight if you can pick
somebody up
you can usually beat their ass
that's why
children don't beat adults asses
okay
um you look at [ __ ] even frank
fazetta paintings a [ __ ]
conan all right
how big is conan we don't know how big
conan is conan
in those paintings is bigger than a
woman
he's about the same size or maybe a
little bit bigger than your average man
but then in other pictures you see him
fighting a [ __ ]
dude like a damn ogre or something with
fangs
and he would be like
me fighting a guy that's [ __ ] six
foot [ __ ] six
okay he's up in the air with his knife
and [ __ ] he's at a disadvantage
so size is relative
um
size matters it doesn't matter how
strong you are that much i mean well i
mean if a person has a foot
of height on you they got reach and
weight on you then yes they're probably
gonna beat your ass right now if a guy's
a foot taller than me but he only weighs
145 pounds that'd be the equivalent of
me
fighting a kite i'd tear him up
but if he weighs this
220 pounds
and i'm just pushing just coming up at
200.
uh
i don't think i'd be at an at an
advantage actually i think a [ __ ]
a six foot
two
220 pound guy
would be at an advantage over me
so all this [ __ ] [ __ ] comes into play
in
what you would call with the quote quote
martial arts
all right
quantity is equality all its own
if your opponent can pick you up
you're at a disadvantage you can't get
any leverage once you're up off the
ground to punch and put enough power
into somebody to knock them out i mean
you can still hurt them but it's just
not as it's not as good as if you were
on the ground
you know
that way you can conduct that leverage
into them
although when you look at paintings of
kona and he's got a bladed weapon so
you're cutting it's so it's different
so unarmed combat and armor combat are
different
you know
arm combat especially if it's something
like bladed weapons or [ __ ]
blunt weapons speed has a lot to do with
it they always show these big club
[ __ ] warhammer type weapons if you
actually go back and look at what
medieval's used
they used war hammers but the end of the
hammer was [ __ ] only a couple pounds
it didn't weigh much they they liked
stuff that was light that you could
swing and hit real quickly over and over
again rapid blows they didn't like these
big [ __ ]
10 pound heads or five pound heads like
you'd see in conan where it was just
oh you know they
speed tends to win
over power
when it comes to that kind of [ __ ]
picture says chuck norris is a party
pooper yeah he i don't think he wasn't
always though i don't think he takes
himself quite as seriously as steven
seagal but he takes himself seriously
enough that he has a hard time like
taking a joke and he's like super super
religious and he's like super like he
wouldn't do
the expendables movies because he's like
well i don't like all the swearing in
that which like
what century do you live in
sorry but
come on like are your sensibilities that
delicate
that you can't listen to somebody say
[ __ ] or something and you're gonna get
all like butt hurt about it come on now
yeah you're supposed to be like some big
badass and you can't even like listen to
somebody swearing you get all like
you know bring me the fainting couch i
don't get it well i think when he got
older he he started to worry too much
about religion and you know sin and
things like that he put a lot of
importance and all that he was just a
dude from another era but as far as i
know when he was young in the 70s he
wasn't really like that
i mean that's the thing like i'm not
gonna [ __ ] on him like he can actually
fight now he can't act that's for sure
but uh but he could actually fight i'm
not gonna like [ __ ] on him for that but
yeah i feel like as he got older yeah he
just got like way way way more uptight
and religious and it's like i can't even
i can't be down with people that can't
even
yeah
listen to people swearing i'm like
that's how people talk at first he could
not really grasp the chuck norris joke
yeah he like he got really offended by
that and like honestly like a few years
back this is a while back but there was
a guy
that kind of made his living he kind of
looked like chuck norris so he kind of
made a living
um
like being a chuck norris impersonator
like he didn't lie and say he was chuck
norris but he's like oh if you're having
a party or some kind of function and you
want somebody to come in that kind of
looks like chuck norris and it's like
i'll pretend to be chuck norris like he
would do that
and like chuck norris sued him you're
right and i was like dude this bro is
probably just like trying to put food on
the table why you want to be that way
like don't be such a [ __ ] like elvis
[ __ ] soon and eva's a person right
it's like why you want to be like that
like look this is just some guy that's
just trying to make a living and what's
what was weird is that the impersonators
and the [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] um the jokes the chuck
norris jokes were actually bolstering
chuck norris's legend right they weren't
making fun of him it's not like steven
seagal where everybody laughs about how
fat or like how like shitty his movies
are yeah like all the chuck norris stuff
was like how like over the top badass he
was so it's like you'd think that he
would embrace it but no it's like he
couldn't even get down with that he felt
insecure about it because he's not as
badass as portrayed that's what i'm
saying and i kind of feel like there may
he that's the whole thing and that's why
he didn't have a sense of humor i kind
of feel like the whole thing about it's
like oh chuck norris he's so badass and
stuff like that but it's like how badass
can you be if you're that insecure yeah
about your masculinity he couldn't lean
into it yeah i'm so badass when i do
push-ups the earth moves right you know
what i mean like if it was me i'd have
been like yeah that's right that's right
you know i'd wear the shirts and
everything yeah i do push-ups and i
don't [ __ ] push up the earth moves
down
[ __ ] you know i mean if i can
but that's to be expected when you're
chuck norris based on the movies that
you made
uh so i don't understand where them of
he evidently backed off on that
eventually
he understood that
they were riffing but it wasn't
it wasn't against him it was it was
about movies i'm like one there's a
character in the movies and
if you're in the public eye if you're in
the public eye in the first place and
your whole persona particularly people
like chuck norris or people like steven
seagal or somebody like that
your whole persona is that oh what a
badass you are now if people start
clowning on that
um
if you get all up in arms about it and
start talking and start taking yourself
all seriously and stuff like steven
seagal does people are going to clown on
you even harder yeah so it's better to
just kind of like go with it
people will like like you a lot better
what have a sense of humor
don't be that insecure well got segal
with several things you're making you
want to watch the stevenson golf movie
i'm not watching one
the accent i mean i could watch it but
i'll probably fall asleep the accents
was one all right what race is steven
seagal okay you don't know what race is
he's all right he's all raises he
represents all yes okay
all right
the other one is the [ __ ] he's the
quintessential earthling yeah
the other one is uh [ __ ] his sexual
orientation the motherfucker's always
trying to do shiatsu on some chicks as
[ __ ] titties to see if they got
[ __ ] cancer or something he's
constantly [ __ ] scoping and scheming
or whatever he's been old
did he wasn't that old back in those
days but he's still
when that riff started dude that's it he
was just in his 30s
and the girls were in their 20s which
they it wasn't that big of a deal but
now he's [ __ ] he's pretty anxious
and he he's like in his
late 50s
he's like
yeah it's gross yeah and he's and he's
scheming after some [ __ ] i mean it's
gross when young dudes do it too but
it's like really gross when old dudes do
it he's like in his [ __ ] late 50s and
and he's not in good shape it's not like
you're talking about [ __ ] big harry
come for your titties and yeah he's not
good and she's like and she's some
japanese chick in [ __ ] her 20s she's
probably and he's got a samurai sword
with a ponytail it's [ __ ] ridiculous
but
but jenny's saying that motherfucker's
so old but the thing is though is that
she knows
that old [ __ ] like david bowie
in her 40s and the 50s were [ __ ]
swanging so mick jagger in his [ __ ]
40s and 50s
yeah but when i say old that doesn't
necessarily mean like biological it's
just it's a it's i've said that before
yeah when i say old i'm not [ __ ] on
old people i'm old too yeah i'm saying
old
uh it's like a spirit is an attitude
it's like a spiritual oldness it's not
necessarily like how old you are in
number i don't give a [ __ ] about that
yeah
but you act like an old person or you
come across like an old person then yeah
you're old but if you don't then then
that's okay they got dudes out there in
their 50s and 60s that can just [ __ ]
swing danny rowling said steven's a
boobologist like he's a biologist yeah
he's got to study the boobs
well yeah all right wait are you going
to give him like a um
are you going to give him like a degree
like a degree from the boob
he wouldn't accept a degree from me
actually you shouldn't give him one
don't don't encourage him no i'm saying
if i were to come up with a degree he
would be like i have my own degree he
would say that he would have made his
own booboology he came up with that
before yeah he would come up with some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] he's like way better
than that yeah he would say he's better
than me and [ __ ] this well he's
better than you at um
a lot
i mean that that's one thing
so you know i'm not worried about it
he's better than you at
that and being in shitty movies i mean
you've never been in he's hilarious he's
in there you've never been in shitty
movies right so
yeah so he's better obviously yeah
i don't know all right so um
let me shut this down jim yeah i'm
making something i'm starving starving
i'll make it something good yeah we'll
be we'll be out uh when uh we'll be back
sunday and we're going to be talking
about
the new
sylvester stallone movie yeah that's
right okay it's america samaritan's free
on um amazon amazon prime it was a good
amazon prime review it's good real good
we're going to be talking about that on
superhero movie
and
um [ __ ]
stallone produced it himself it's under
his own company they pulled a superhero
out of thin air it's not a
he made up a superhero
i mean you know might as well yeah and
it [ __ ] did good
it was good now i will say
i don't know i'll save it for sunday
maybe but i was gonna say i thought it
was a little bit of a
i don't want to say ripoff that's like
that sounds well everything's a ripoff
in the superhero that's true there's
some stuff that happened in here like oh
i see where you got that they were
homage in a bunch of stuff yeah okay um
but i think i think it's a one-off i
don't think they'll do another one but
it's uh it's good it's good it was yeah
it was entertaining it was good
entertaining yeah yeah the samaritan on
[ __ ] just called samaritan
samaritan's samaritan it's on amazon
prime i think it's an amazon prime
original yeah if you like superheroes
yeah it was it's worth it all right so
we'll be back on
sunday talking about that
uh so thanks for hanging out with us
this evening doing the taste test on the
colt 45 which is much better than i was
expecting so yeah
uh well maybe d came through maybe we'll
do another taste test on next friday
yeah dude we'll see how it goes well
yeah we'll go to the liquor store and
see what we can come up with we'll see
what we can yeah
uh but yeah so thanks for dropping by
thanks for super chats we will see you
guys again on sunday evening
good
night